Nicht.
Erik, sag mal was. Falsches Mikrofon eingeschaltet. Schönen guten Abend.
Hallo beim Chaosradio 104.
Mach du das mal.
Ist eigentlich mein Mikro richtig? Ich hör hier totales Echo und alles.
Schalt mal, kann sein, dass du da den falschen Abhörpunkt. Leuchtet bei dir ein Knopf, wo Radio drauf steht?
Nee, egal. Solange ich vernünftig klinge draußen, dann geht das schon. Machen wir gleich erstmal alles. Wir wollen heute Abend reden über den Sicherheitswahn, der uns bevorsteht zwischen Bundestagswahl und den schrecklichen Anschlägen von London. Kaum waren die Opfer geborgen, gab es die ersten Forderungen nach mehr Videoüberwachung, nach Aufzeichnungen von sämtlichen Telefongesprächen, also den Telefondaten und E-Mails, Internet, alles soll überprüft werden. Es gab Überlegungen, ob wir vielleicht irgendwelche Bilderkennungssysteme, Gesichtserkennungssysteme an die Videoüberwachungssysteme knüpfen können. Leute haben ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht, ob man vielleicht ihren U-Bahn-Gast vorher röntgen kann oder irgendwie das Gepäck absuchen kann. Wir wollen heute Abend mal diese ganzen Sachen ein bisschen beleuchten, wollen mit euch darüber reden, was denkt ihr? Haltet ihr das für eine angemessene Sicherheitsmaßnahme oder glaubt ihr, dass es der Demokratie schädlich ist? Wie fühlt ihr euch dabei, wenn ihr permanent von Videokameras überwacht wird? Glaubt ihr, dass es der Sicherheit dient oder fühlt ihr euch eher unwohl dabei? Und wir haben zwei Experten im Studio noch dazu.
Das eine ist der Erik, das Mikrofon jetzt hoffentlich funktioniert. Sag mal was Erik. Aha, das klingt schon etwas besser. Du musst natürlich ein wenig näher an das Mikrofon ran gehen.
Das ist bei dem Stuhl ein bisschen schwierig.
Apokalyptische Geräusche. Der Erik ist von der TU Berlin, hat mitgearbeitet in einem Projekt zum Thema Videoüberwachung. Das heißt, er hat wissenschaftlich fundierte Erkenntnisse gewonnen, oder? Und der Ralf von der Uni Bremen. Was machst du an der Uni Bremen? Warst du nicht mal hier in Berlin auch?
Ich war mal in Berlin, bin im Moment noch am Pendeln, bin aber seit zwei Jahren an der Uni Bremen angestellt in einem Projekt zu Datenschutzregulation im Internet und bin nebenbei noch aktiv in diversen Netzpolitikorganisationen, vor allem im Moment European Digital Rights, wo es auch viel um Datenvorratsspeicherung im Internet geht.
Auch das ist unser Thema hier im Chaosradio 104 und ihr an den Radio seid herzlich eingeladen, mitzureden. An der Fritz-Watt-Line anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Hubschrauber-Einsätze sind ja doch eher die Diener der Aufklärung oder auch der Prävention. Also Graffiti-Sprayer wollen sie auch damit fangen, nachdem gesprüht wurde.
Richtig, wir hatten ja letztens in Berlin erst die große Diskussion darüber, wo es darum ging, ob Graffiti-Sprayer nachts von Hubschraubern vom Bundesgrenzturz verfolgt werden sollen oder nicht. Wo sie den Leuten gesagt haben, sie können nachts nicht mehr schlafen, wenn die Hubschrauber dadurch die Häuser kreisen. Überhaupt wäre das ja wohl ein bisschen überdimensioniert alles. Da passt das Lied natürlich wie Faust aufs Auge. Aber auch insgesamt soll es ein bisschen demonstrieren, dass da möglicherweise manchmal ein bisschen mit falschem Maß gemessen wird oder da auch gerade bei den Forderungen nach so einem Maßnahmen dann mal maßlos überzogen wird. Möglicherweise.
Chaosradio 104, Verzeihung, Chaosradio 104 ist es, was ihr hört. Und um die Videoüberwachung und sonstige technische Maßnahmen zwischen, wie hast du es genannt, zwischen?
Zwischen London und Bundestagswahl.
Zwischen London und der Bundestagswahl, da geht es heute Abend in der Sendung. Ja, der sogenannte internationale Terrorismus oder islamistische Terrorismus der Internationale ist wieder mal ein willkommener Grund für insbesondere die Innenminister der Länder und auch des Bundes einige bürgerliche Freiheitsrechte einzuschränken oder abzuschaffen. Auf den Prüfstand zu stellen, wie es so schön heißt. Genau. Reform heißt ja mittlerweile auch Abbau. Auf den Prüfstand zu stellen und eins, was sie sehr gerne auf den Prüfstand gestellt haben wollen, ist natürlich die Videoüberwachung. Da hat auch insbesondere der bayerische Innenminister Günther Beckstein sich sehr hervorgetan. Der hat nämlich vor über einem halben Jahr schon gefordert, dass es doch langsam an der Zeit wäre, zumindest die Autobahn, die Bundesautobahn lückenlos Video zu überwachen, damit man eben dann auch viel schneller Straftätern nachkommen kann, also geklaute Autos finden kann.
Und gleichzeitig ging das natürlich nicht um Videoüberwachung, also nicht um das Bild, sondern um das Kennzeichen. Also die Technik, die wir jetzt in den Mautbrücken ja schon eingebaut haben, soll dann im Prinzip flächendeckend nicht nur für LKWs, sondern auch für Kraftfahrzeuge eingeführt werden. Das heißt, dass dann wirklich alle Fahrzeuge, die über die Autobahn fahren, standardmäßig gegen mögliche Fahndungslisten abgeglichen werden oder natürlich auch aktuell dann mal kurz zwischengespeichert werden und der Polizei zugänglich gemacht werden. Das heißt, die Polizei kann dann im Prinzip auf Knopfdruck an sich, also die Technik würde es mindestens hergeben, auf Knopfdruck feststellen, wo denn ein bestimmtes Auto gerade ist, auf welchem Autobahnabschnitt.
Wenn es eingebaut ist in die Mautbrücken, Erik, wird es dann auch gemacht? Ohne was sie es uns erzählen?
Also, das würde ich in Deutschland nicht von ausgehen.
Warum nicht?
Weil die Datenschutztradition hier doch eine relativ starke ist und sich die Polizei da weitgehend, ich meine sicher gibt es Einzelfälle, aber weitgehend dran hält.
Also wir hatten ja gerade im Zug der Videoüberwachung, wer heute ein bisschen tagsüber Fritz gehört hat, es war ja ein Themenschwerpunkt heute Morgen. Es ging darum, dass die Berliner U-Bahn jetzt ein bisschen mehr Video überwacht wird. Wer U-Bahn fährt, aufmerksam U-Bahn fährt, wird gemerkt haben, dass die neueren U-Bahn-Züge auf jeden Fall auch alle eine Videokamera eingebaut haben. Das sind sogenannte Dome-Kameras oder Fixed-Dome-Kameras. Das heißt also welche, die sich nicht drehen, aber trotzdem so einen halbrunden dunkelgrauen oder dunkelgetönten halbrunnen Kreis unten dran haben und da ist eine Kamera drunter. Diese Kamera zeichnet alles auf, also nimmt elektronisch alles auf, was in der U-Bahn passiert. Jede Person, die da sitzt und was sie tut. Und je nachdem, ob denen was vorgefallen ist oder nicht, können die Daten gespeichert und hinterher auch ausgewertet werden. Es ist jetzt ein Modellversuch, so heißt es, für Berlin auch beschlossen worden, wo diese Überwachung ausgeweitet werden soll und die Daten auch 24 Stunden gespeichert werden dürfen.
Find ich das gut oder find ich das schlecht?
Ja, das sollen wir eigentlich von euch wissen.
0331 70 97 110 Gefällt es euch in der U-Bahn zu sitzen, die mit einer Videokamera überwacht wird? Oder gefällt es euch gerade nicht? Und wenn es euch gefällt, warum gefällt es euch? Wenn es euch nicht gefällt, warum gefällt es euch nicht? 0331 70 97 110 Sie sind eingeladen zu berichten an der Fritz-Otline und hier im Chaosradio 104.
Jo, und vom Eric würde ich gerne mal wissen, wie Berlin denn da eigentlich insgesamt aufgestellt ist. Das heißt also, das, was der Herr Körting, unser Insenator heute gesagt hat, klang eigentlich ganz vernünftig, dass er gesagt hat, dass es also nicht unbedingt mehr Sicherheit bringt und dass es eigentlich nicht das Ziel der Berliner Regierung ist, dass sie da unbedingt, also der Berliner Landesregierung, dass sie da nicht unbedingt mehr Überwachung haben wollen und dass man das schon irgendwie auf Schwerpunkte, auf Brennpunkte begrenzen müsste. Wie ist es insgesamt im gesamten deutschen oder im europäischen Kontext mit der Videoüberwachung hier in Berlin?
Also man muss unterscheiden, denke ich, zwischen privater und polizeilicher Videoüberwachung. In einer polizeilichen Videoüberwachung ist Berlin heute eigentlich die große Ausnahme, weil es keine Überwachung von, also keine polizeiliche Videoüberwachung öffentlicher Straßen und Plätzen in Berlin gibt. Im Gegensatz zu diversen anderen Bundesländern. Berlin ist da wirklich noch zusammen mit Schleswig-Holstein und Hamburg derzeit die große Ausnahme. Wobei in Schleswig-Holstein und Hamburg auch kürzlich, oder in Hamburg kürzlich das Polizeigesetz geändert wurde. In Schleswig-Holstein soll es kommen.
Woher kommt es, dass gerade die drei Bundesländer noch die Ausnahmen sind? Verpennt, Faulheit oder ist das politisch?
Politische Konstellation. Also einfach hier in Berlin, Rot-Rote-Koalition. In Hamburg, der lange Zeit ein SPD-regierter Sinn hat. In Schleswig-Holstein halt auch eben ein SPD. Und das hat sich mit den Wahlergebnissen in den letzten Monaten, Jahren geändert.
Das heißt also, wir sind da eigentlich noch so ganz gut freiheitlich gesehen.
Andere Städte sehen ja glaube ich anders aus. London ist glaube ich fast flächendeckend überwacht. Und wir haben eine Anruferin aus Dresden. Hallo Elisabeth. Du kommst gerade aus London zurück.
Ja das ist richtig. Also in London ist ja sehr viel Video überwacht, wie ich heute festgestellt habe und die letzten Tage. Besonders halt auch die U-Bahn. Aber ich muss sagen also in den U-Bahnen oder so, das hat mich jetzt nicht besonders gestört, dass ich da überwacht werde.
Ist es denn da wirklich auch sichtbar? Also das heißt sieht man die Kameras oder sind die dann eher versteckt angebracht?
Die sind eigentlich ziemlich sichtbar. Also in den Tunnels, also auch in den Bahnen an sich und in der Stadt auch. Also man sieht die schon.
Und wie fühlst du dich insgesamt dabei? Also das heißt sozusagen, wo wäre für dich die Schmerzgrenze bei Kameras? Wie weit würdest du dich von Kameras noch verfolgen lassen?
Also ich sag mal so, wenn das an irgendwelchen Sicherheitsgebieten ist, also oder wo die Öffentlichkeit viel zusammentrifft, wie jetzt in U-Bahnen oder in irgendwelchen öffentlichen großen Einrichtungen, dann ist es okay, aber sobald das dann halt wirklich in die Privatsphären reingehen würde, dann hört es natürlich auf.
Da gab es mal eine legendäre Webcam, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es sie noch gibt, in Frankfurt am Main auf irgendeinem Bankgebäude. Das war eine schwenkbare, zoombare Webcam, damit konntest du wirklich ins Wohngebäude gegenüber reingucken und Gesichter erkennen, wenn du wolltest. Fällt mir da gerade ein. Vielleicht kennt jemand noch die Adresse von dieser Kamera, wir wären sehr dankbar, wenn wir das mal gesagt kriegten. Ebenfalls 0331 77 97 110. Elisabeth, aus welchen Gründen würdest du denn befürworten, dass Kameras da sind?
Also gerade so in den U-Bahnen oder so, man hat ja bei den Anschlägen dann gemerkt, dass man dann relativ schnell auf die Täter kommen konnte dadurch. Oder auch bei den Autobahnen, denke ich mal auch, Unfall, Vorhergänge besser nachzuvollziehen, ist vielleicht gar nicht schlecht.
Also zur Aufklärung hinterher.
Ja.
Glaubst du den Politikern, die sagen, sie könnten damit Anschläge oder Überfälle oder sonst irgendwas verhindern?
Verhindern alleine durch Videobewachung ist eigentlich nicht. Also man sieht es denen ja dann nicht an, dass es irgendwelche Übeltäter, sag ich mal, sein könnten. Also Prävention von Videokameras, das ist eigentlich nicht möglich, oder?
Wir behaupten auch nein, aber was wissen wir schon.
Erik, gibt es denn irgendwelche Zahlen, irgendwelche Studien zu dem Erfolg, also zum Fahndungserfolg? Kann man da irgendwie einen Trend sagen? Ist es ein gültiges Argument zu sagen, dass die im Nachhinein zur Fahndung erfolgreich eingesetzt werden?
Also in der Fahndung, praktisch auf der repressiven Seite, ist es natürlich ein relativ erfolgreiches Instrument, wie ja jetzt praktisch auch die Aufnahmen gezeigt haben, die sehr schnell hervorgezaubert haben. Lange Zeit aber, und das ist, finde ich, jetzt der große Wandel, der eigentlich gemacht wird. Lange Zeit wurde Videoüberwachung mit dem Argument verkauft, dass es Kriminalität verhindern würde. Und wenn man jetzt eigentlich umschwenkt zu dem repressiven Argument, man könnte Täter schnell erfassen, dann muss man sich halt fragen, ja klar, also mag sein und ist sicher auch richtig, hat London gezeigt. Aber heiligt der Zweck die Mittel, also wie weit dürfen wir gehen, was können wir alles machen, ist es notwendig irgendwie, dass vielleicht jeder irgendwie einen DNA-Test kurz nach der Geburt abgibt, weil dann Kriminalität besser verfolgt werden kann.
Das wird ja auch bereits diskutiert in Großbritannien.
Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Hast du da was von mitgekriegt, Elisabeth?
Nicht so richtig, nee.
Obwohl praktisch die Überwachung die ganze Zeit um einen rum ist, diskutiert der Londoner das nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das jetzt dort schon gang gäbe ist. Vielleicht haben die dann ganz anderes. Die finden das halt vielleicht anders zu haben.
Okay, ich danke dir, Elisabeth.
Ja.
Und gute Nacht. Ach nee, Oliver, ach so, das ist jetzt, ah, nee, also jetzt versteh's. Oliver ist gar nicht dran, sondern wollte nur die Nachricht loswerden, dass die Kamera bei der Frankfurter Rundschau auf dem Dach montiert ist.
Ich glaube, die ist aber dennoch dringend der Datenschützer hin.
Ich weiß es nicht. Wir haben in irgendeinem der Chaosradios von einem Jahr ungefähr, haben wir da mal mit rumgespielt. Das war ganz lustig. Der Marc aus Freiburg hat angerufen. Hallo, Marc. Du wolltest eine Kamera petzen?
Ja, ach petzen, zum petzen ist es zu spät, weil die wichtigste Einschränkung hat schon wieder stattgefunden, nachdem Leute aus Freiburg sich dann endlich beschwert hatten. Aber es ist eine ähnliche Geschichte wie die Sache mit der Frankfurter Rundschau. Es gab hier eine Kamera in Freiburg auf dem Rathausplatz, die war oberhalb eines Hotels angebracht, beziehungsweise ist es noch, aber wurde jetzt entsprechend in ihren Fähigkeiten etwas eingeschränkt. Da konnte man wunderbar den Leuten beim Eiskaffee zuschauen, konnte dann in die Ausschnitte der jungen Damen schauen, die dort sitzen. Und naja, ich denke, sowas gibt es nicht nur auf dem Rathausplatz, das hat es auch schon an der PH in Freiburg gegeben, an der Pädagogischen Hochschule. Da konnte man den Mädels beim Surfen zuschauen.
Ach schön, Police Academy.
Also der Freiburg macht sich da Namen mit. Wir hatten auch schon Schwimmbadkabinen, also Damenkabinen, die überwacht wurden, Video überwacht wurden.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen, ne?
Ja, aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Natürlich, was denkst du denn?
Ja, und die ganze Freiburger Innenstadt ist ja sowieso von der VHG Video überwacht.
Warst du schon mal bei Media Markt einkaufen?
Es ist lange her.
Bei Media Markt filmt eine Kamera oberhalb der Kasse, wenn du die Geheimzahl zu deiner EC-Karte in das Gerät eintippst, um zu bezahlen.
Tue ich nicht, zahlbar.
Ja, sollte man den Media Markt zumindest machen, weil ich weiß nämlich nicht, was da dann irgendwie für 1-Euro-Kräfte an den Kameras sitzen und sich mal eben die PIN abschreiben.
Wahnsinn, aber sag mal, wie stehst du zu der Videoüberwachung? Glaubst du, dass das für dich ein valides Mittel ist, um hinterher Fahndungserfolge zu bekommen oder zweifelst du da dran?
Also ich halte sowieso die ganze Hetze mit dem Terror für Quatsch. Wer einmal Chomsky gelesen hat, der, naja, Chomsky nennt das die Matrix und sagt im Grunde, dass wir ganz schön an der Nase geführt werden. Da stecken ja ganz andere Gründe dahinter, warum jetzt diese Überwachung durchgeführt wird und dieser ganze Krieg und so weiter.
Was sagt Chomsky, warum die Überwachung durchgeführt wird?
Na ja, Chomsky führt einfach andere Gründe an, als die, die man in den Tagesthemen sieht. Er sagt, wir sind die Terroristen, wir paktieren mit Regierungen, die absolut korrupt sind. Wir ziehen den ganzen Hass auf uns und besonders die USA, die da so voranpreschen und das ganze alles wollen, die sichern sich natürlich ihre Ölbeserven.
Nicht doch, nicht doch, nicht doch. Der Krieg gegen den Irak hätte auch stattgefunden, wenn die Bananen exportieren würden.
Ja, ist gut.
Und mit Videokameras in der Londoner U-Bahn sich hat man auch keine Ölreserven, oder?
Genau, und T-Bet wird demnächst geholfen.
Das ist richtig, so holen wir uns zurück zum Thema. Ja, mit der Videoüberwachung, ich bin ein ganz, ganz großer Feind dieser Geschichte, weil ich das Gefühl hab, ich möchte einfach wissen, wer mich sieht, bei was er mich sieht, ob das jetzt an der Kasse ist mit der EC-Karte oder ob ich mir nur in der Nase probe in Freiburgs Innenstadt. Man könnte statt der Videoüberwachung genauso Leute anstellen, die dort stehen, die präsent sind, und die mir ins Auge gucken, wenn sie mich anschauen.
Die könnten dann sogar noch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ein bisschen zur Hand gehen, wenn du zu viele Einkäufe ins Auto laden musst oder irgendwie so.
Genau, richtig, ja. Und ich denke, da steckt einfach eine ganz große Industrie dahinter aus Amerika, die daran interessiert ist, hier ihre Milliarden zu machen. Und naja, Schili und Beckstein ziehen mit.
Aber warum ziehen die mit? Sind die blöd? Ich weigere mich immer zu glauben, dass Otto Schili so greis ein so greiser Innenminister ist, dass er das einfach frisst, dass er das einfach glaubt, ähnlich Beckstein.
Ich glaube, dass sie da schon ein gewisses Kalkül auch hinter haben. Also zumindestens Schili, und da stelle ich das mal, dass er so schlau ist und sagt, okay, wir befriedigen damit Bevölkerungsbedürfnisse. Also die letzten Umfragen zur Videoüberwachung sind ja erschreckend, da glauben noch tatsächlich 80% der Leute daran, dass das gegen alles helfen würde und die Kriminalität eindämmen würde und gegen Terroranschläge helfen würde. Also zumindest in England finden 80% oder sogar mehr der Bevölkerung Videoüberwachung gut. Und ich glaube, die letzten Zahlen aus Deutschland sind dann nicht viel anders. Und insofern sagen die halt, naja gut, wir geben denen halt so ein bisschen Videoüberwachung, dann ist man wieder ruhig, sind man wieder 80% befriedigt, anstatt dann für die nächste Wahl zu warten, auf die nächste Wahl zu warten. Und da wird dann eben aus diesen innenpolitischen Gründen oder sicherheitspolitischen Gründen dann eben die CDU gewählt.
Das mag gut sein, aber die Frage ist, was da, naja gut, letztendlich bleibt es sich egal, aber was da war es bedingt. Also wenn ich jetzt natürlich rumbrille und sage, wir brauchen Videoüberwachung, ja und dann die Bevölkerung frag, kriegen wir sicher ein anderes Ergebnis, als wenn ich ohne vorher rumgebrüllt zu haben, dass wir mehr Überwachung brauchen, die Bevölkerung dann befrag. Also ich glaube, es ist auch so ein bisschen Populismus dabei, so ein bisschen Stimmung machen.
Das wollen wir heute Abend klären, das heißt also, welche technischen Möglichkeiten bietet die Videoüberwachung, wie realistisch ist es, dass da wirklich Leute auch entdeckt werden und ist möglicherweise präventiv auch irgendwie hilfreich. Auch was Verdrängung angeht bzw. das den Straftaten eben nicht mehr, zumindest nicht mehr vor den Kameras passieren.
Ich kann da noch eine nette Anekdote anbringen. Ich habe vorher in einem Bereich gearbeitet, im Turgismusbereich, kann ich ruhig sagen, in der Fliegerei. Da hat man die Sache natürlich auch sich mal gut durchdacht, ob das jetzt was bringt. Gerade nach dem 1. September, ich musste am 12. September fliegen, und habe mir dann auch mal überlegt, was da alles so passieren könnte und so weiter. Man spielt natürlich mit dem Gedanken, dass man eine Bombe an Bord sein könnte.
Spielst du am 12. September tatsächlich stärker mit dem Gedanken als vorher? Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist doch genauso groß wie am 9.
September auch, oder nicht?
Das ist richtig, aber man hat es sich halt so durch den Kopf gehen lassen. Und worauf ich hinaus will, ist, du kommst dann so auf Flughäfen wie Amsterdam Skip Hole zum Beispiel, da ist, ich weiß nicht, wie viele 100 Kameras die da haben, 100 Kameras oder mehr mittlerweile, ich weiß es nicht, also der ganze Flughafen ist wie du überwacht und du fühlst dich wirklich beobachtet. Aber was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, dann hörst du dann so Sprüche, wenn du an der Kontrolle durchläufst, wirst du gescreened und dann sagt der Sicherheitswahn, der sollst bitte alles auspacken aus der Tasche und mach da im Grunde ein Lärm. Und dann kommt der Kapitän an die Reihe und packt schmunzend seine Sachen aus, ist dann aber irgendwann genervt und sagt zu ihm, wissen Sie, wenn ich einen Flugzeug entführen möchte, dann tanke ich voll.
Das ist eigentlich so der Satz, der zeigt, wie blöd du nicht das ganze System ist.
Und das regt mich eigentlich auf, dass da so viel Hype drum gemacht wird und dass da diese Industrie dahinter steckt, die uns so ein Stück weit wirklich, also ein ganzes Stück weit, glaube ich, an der Nase herumführt und uns glauben lässt, wir sind ja ach so sicher. Naja, und dann passiert es halt, obwohl London doch so toll videoüberwacht ist, passiert halt doch sowas, ne?
Ja, die Kosten, die Kosten der Videoüberwachung.
Na interessant wäre mal, gibt's, haben wir Zahlen, verlässliche Zahlen darüber, wie groß der Jahresumsatz oder der jährliche Umsatz in eben diesem Bereich ist, also sicherer private Sicherheitsbranche. Padelun wird sowas wissen.
Padelun wird sowas wissen.
Hört er zu? Dann soll er mal anrufen, Padelun ruf mal an. 0331 77 97 110, du wirst sowas wissen. Marc, vielen Dank.
Alles klar, ich danke euch.
Warte mal, hier drücke ich wieder, jetzt kommt wieder ein Geräusch, das ich nicht will.
Wenn Fritz in Neukölln, dann 102, 6.
Fritz Info.
In der Nacht erwarten uns mal mehr, mal weniger Wolken, teilweise regnet es auch. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen 18 und 14 Grad. Morgen bleibt es dann meistens wolkig, es gibt einzelne Schauer und Gewitter nur im Süden Brandenburgs. Es ist weitgehend heiter. Die Temperaturen steigen morgen auf. 30 bis 35 Grad und jetzt gibt es Meldungen mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
In Ostdeutschland rote in den kommenden 15 Jahren ein massiver Stellenverlust. Laut einer Studie der Bundesagentur für Arbeit könnten bis zu eine Million Jobs verloren gehen. Die Aussichten seien damit noch schlechter als vor Jahren angenommen, heißt es. Im größten Kinderschänderprozess Frankreichs hat ein Gericht die Urteile gesprochen. Die Richter verhängten hohe Haftstrafen. Die über 60 Täter hatten insgesamt 45 Kinder missbraucht, das jüngste Opfer war sechs Monate alt. Die vorbeugende Telefonüberwachung in Niedersachsen ist verfassungswidrig. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden. Niedersachsen wollte der Polizei ermöglichen, ohne konkreten Tatverdacht Telefongespräche abzuhören. Zum Fußball im Liga-Pokal schlug der FC Schalke 04 Werder Bremen 2 zu 1. Der Verkehr auf Fritzer 2 Berliner Ring Richtung Magdeburg zwischen Brandenburg und Wollin ist die Ausfahrt gesperrt, hier liegt ein LKW direkt an der Anstoßstelle. Und nochmal LKW-Problem, und zwar auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Dreieck-Spray auch Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Königswusterhausen und dem Kreuz Schönefelder Kreuz. Hier auch Behinderungen durch einen defekten LKW, bitte vorsichtig fahren.
Vielen Dank Matthias, eine nach halb elf.
Fritz, eine Produktion des RBB.
Er spricht, die Zeltplatzleitung.
Guten Morgen liebe Camping-Freunde.
Fritz sendet.
Die lange Fritz-Sommernacht des Campings.
Alles um und übers Zelten. Eure Geschichten über durchgeringerte Zelte, Rezepte für einflammige Gaskocher, die erfolgreich versprechendsten Mückenabwehrstrategien und Tipps für die schönsten Campingplätze in Berlin, Brandenburg, Europa und der Welt.
Mit den Radio-Fritzen Marco Seifert und Nicole Markwald im Studio und Fritz-Reportern unterwegs.
Eine lange Nacht lang.
Die lange Fritz-Sommernacht des Campings.
Kommenden Freitag ab 22 Uhr, die ganze lange Sommernacht bis morgens um 6.
Mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
Chaosradio 104 habt ihr eingeschaltet. Das Ganze auf Fritz, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat im Rahmen des Blue Moons. Und die heutige Sendung, die befindet sich zwischen London und der Bundestagswahl. Es geht heute Abend im Chaosradio 104.
Und Frank, was machst du da?
Der Nachrichtensprecher ist viel kleiner als ich, dementsprechend ist das Mikrofon natürlich vollkommen verstellbar. Ich probier's jetzt.
Es geht, dass ich meinen schönen Faden verloren. Ihr seid alle schuld.
Zwischen Bundestagswahl und London, nicht umgekehrt.
Zwischen London und Bundestagswahl, ja, es geht heute Abend.
Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand, das Thema.
Genau, der Sicherheitswahn der Behörden, der Politik, den könnt ihr euch tagtäglich angucken. Also als sich jeder eine Spast aus Brandenburg mit seinem Ultra-Leichtsegler vor dem Reichstag plattgemacht hat, da hieß es ja auch erst mal wieder, wir müssen sofort ein Flugverbot über Berlin und so. Insbesondere der brandenburgische Innenminister Schönbohm hat sich da nicht gerade mit Ruhm bekleckert, den hab ich in einem Interview gesehen, wo er gesagt hat, dass das alles, ja das wäre ja, Körting wäre ja selber schuld, was gestattet er auch, dass die Leute da so lang fliegen dürfen. Eine halbe Stunde später war dann jemand von der Flugsicherung da und meinte, ja da könnt ihr Flugverbote machen, wie ihr wollt. Ein Ultra-Leichtflugzeug werden wir nie finden, wenn einer damit nach Berlin reinfliegt. Also ein Radar, das überhaupt nicht erfassen kann. Die fliegen so niedrig, dass das Radar gestört wird. Ja darüber hinaus ist Videoüberwachung ein gern genommenes Thema, nicht nur von Politikern und Polizisten, sondern auch von uns hier im Chaosradio. Fritz und ich sind herzlich eingeladen, natürlich über das Thema mit uns zu reden, unter 0331 70 97 110.
Wir haben es gerade in den Nachrichten gehört, die präventive Telefonüberwachung ist vom Verfassungsgericht abgesegt worden, zumindestens für Niedersachsen, für das Polizeigesetz dort. Telefonüberwachung, vor allem präventiv, das heißt also, bevor irgendwas passiert ist. Nach den Anschlägen von London wurde natürlich auch mal wieder gefordert, dass man alle Verbindungsdaten von allen Telefonen, Internet-Einwahlen, E-Mails, alles speichern sollte. Es gibt auf EU-Ebene auch Ambitionen, das tatsächlich auch festzuschreiben. Das heißt also, dass zumindestens das europaweit in den Mitgliedsländern entsprechend umgesetzt werden muss. Das heißt also, dann die Internet-Provider und Telefonfirmen müssten dann sämtliche Telefonverbindungen, also nicht die Gespräche, nicht die Inhalte, sondern wer mit wem wann telefoniert hat, wer sich wann wie ins Internet eingewählt hat. Und sie wollen auch feststellen, wer mit dem Laptop in welchem Wireless-Lahn wann online war. Und so ganz absurde Sachen. Ralf, kannst du da ein bisschen was berichten zu dem aktuellen Stand, wie da so die Bemühungen gerade laufen?
Ja, das zieht sich ja in der EU schon seit Jahren hin. Und das hat auch schon längst vor dem 11. September 2001 angefangen. Mit der ganzen Idee, das Internet ist ja sowieso ein Tummelplatz von Kriminellen und Kinderpornografie-Händlern und Terroristen. Kennt ihr ja alle. Und natürlich Musikpiraten. Und deswegen wird das seit Jahr und Tag auf EU-Ebene und woanders verfolgt, dass sozusagen die Internet-Provider gezwungen werden, 12 Monate mindestens, teilweise auch länger, die ganzen Verbindungsdaten aufzubewahren. Im Moment werden die ja nur für 90 Tage oder so gespeichert zu Abrechnungszwecken, wenn man keine Flatrate hat. Jetzt nach London ist es natürlich wieder direkt auf den Tisch gekommen. Unglücklicherweise hat im Moment auch noch Großbritannien die Präsidentschaft in der EU, hat da also auch deutlichere Eingriffsrecht, also Möglichkeiten, da sozusagen die Tagesordnung zu bestimmen. Und es gibt seit ein paar Tagen einen neuen Entwurf, der Innen- und Justizminister der EU, wo eben jetzt vorgeschlagen wird, wie das konkret laufen soll. Und die Briten wollen wirklich versuchen, das bis zum Herbst noch durch zu pushen. Das Europäische Parlament ist massiv dagegen.
Das Parlament ist dagegen?
Das ist dagegen. Die haben sich vor ein paar Monaten sehr eindeutig hinter einen Bericht eines deutschen FDP-Abgeordneten zu dem Thema gestellt, der eindeutig gesagt hat, Vorratsspeicherung von Internetdaten für jeden, ohne irgendein Verdachtsmoment oder so, ist verfassungswidrig, Grundrechtewidrig, viel zu teuer für die Provider, geht nicht.
Angenommen, es wäre bezahlbar und angenommen, es wäre nicht verfassungswidrig oder zweifelhaft. Gibt es irgendwelche gesicherten Erkenntnisse darüber, dass das was nutzen würde?
Also es gibt Leute, die haben das mal ausgerechnet, wenn man alleine in Deutschland sämtliche Internetverbindungsdaten, das heißt nicht nur, wann habe ich mich eingewählt, sondern wirklich welche einzelne Webseite habe ich wann besucht und wo habe ich mich weitergeklickt, an wen habe ich eine E-Mail geschickt und so. Nur die Verbindungsdaten, nicht mal die Inhalte dieses ganzen Verkehrs. Wenn man das alles speichern würde, bräuchte man mehrere Terabyte an Festplattenkapazität pro Tag und das alles dann sinnvoll zu durchsuchen, ist ein Höllenaufwand. Also da kann vielleicht Frank vom CCC noch ein bisschen mehr zu sagen, ich bin ja nur Politikwissenschaftler, habe vor 20 Jahren das letzte Mal gehackt. Aber das wichtige finde ich aber hierbei sozusagen aus meiner Perspektive, dass das politische Argument oder auch das rechtliche Argument, es ist einfach verdammt noch mal verfassungswidrig und Grundrechtewidrig, widerspricht auch der europäischen Grundrechtskater, dass man von Leuten einfach pauschal sozusagen alle Bewegungen im virtuellen Raum aufzeichnet. Und die Vorschläge der EU-Innenminister gehen da sogar noch weiter. Die wollen nicht nur Internetdaten speichern, sondern auch Telefondaten, Verbindungsdaten und von Handys jeweils den Standort noch, also in welcher Funkzelle man gerade eingeloggt war. Das heißt, sie würden dann einfach von jeder Person in der Europäischen Union zwölf Monate lang das Bewegungsprofil aufzeichnen und das geht wirklich ein bisschen weit.
Warum geht das weit? Also gegen welche Grundrechte verstößt das?
Gegen das Grundrecht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Also wir sind einfach eine offene Gesellschaft und wir sollen das Recht hier haben, uns bewegen zu können, ohne dass uns der Staat immer hinterherguckt. Oder wir sogar noch gezwungen werden, das selber aufzuzeichnen.
Besteht die Gefahr, also wenn die Parlamente, ich sage mal die Parlamente, weil vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch das eine oder andere nationale Parlament, das ein bisschen schlauer ist oder ein bisschen mehr im Sinne seiner Bürger denkt, wenn die Parlamente dagegen sind, besteht auch nicht die Gefahr, da gibt es dann vielleicht irgendwelche Bestrebungen, einfach die Grundrechte zu ändern, dass man einfach, okay wir ändern das Grundgesetz, wir schränken das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung ein und zwar explizit.
Das wird schwierig, weil zum Beispiel im deutschen Grundgesetz ja explizit so ein Paragraf drin ist, nachdem die ersten, ich glaube, 20 Artikel niemals geändert werden dürfen, auch nicht mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit. Und das sind eben genau die Artikel, wo die Grundrechte drin stehen.
Ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, auch anzurufen im Chaos Radio 104 und mitzureden. Heute ist es ja ein weniger technisches, ein mehr gesellschaftliches.
Grüße dich. Während der Autofahrt bin ich ja auf die Sendung aufmerksam geworden und hatte auch mit großem Interesse meinen Vorredner, mein Vorgegner, der davon aufmerksam zugehört. Und ja, kann seine Meinung eigentlich nicht so wirklich sein. Ich meine mal so, mein persönlicher Eindruck, da kann ich aber auch wirklich nur für mich sprechen von dem, was ich höre und lese. Wenn Herr Schilley auspacken würde von dem, was er so obszere macht. Ich meine, wenn man ihn so hörte in Nachrichten, von dem, was man so hört, wie er es sagt, er sagt bei weit nicht alles, was er weiß und was seine Mitarbeiter wissen. Also ich bin der Meinung, wenn die halt wirklich auspacken würden, was sie wirklich am Tisch besprechen, dann würden wir alle, glaube ich, uns überhaupt gar nicht mehr rauskauen. Und das kann es ja auch nicht, aber so weit darf es eigentlich auch gar nicht kommen.
Ja, aber was glaubst du, was die Dienste in Deutschland wissen, was die Bevölkerung nicht weiß? Also ich habe immer das Gefühl, als wäre eine vernünftige Zeitungsredaktion, wie zum Beispiel von der Süddeutschen, als wären die besser informiert als sämtliche Dienste dieser Republik.
Das kann böse klingen jetzt, was ich behaupte, aber dem kann durchaus so sein. Also manchmal wissen Journalisten halt mehr als irgendwelche hochrangigen Politiker, obwohl die natürlich aus erster Hand sagen, informiert zu werden. Man weiß es gar nicht, ja.
Was erwartest du, was Schilly weiß?
Ja, ich weiß, ich keine Ahnung, vielleicht, dass er irgendwelche Sachen irgendwann auspackt. Er muss ja irgendwelche Berater haben, die George Stavio Bush auch sie hat. Und George Stavio Bush, um mal jetzt mal einen Vergleich zu machen, jeder Politiker, egal welchen Amt es ist, hat seine Berater und nicht umsonst. Und soweit er auf deren Meinung vertraut an jeder Politiker, bleibt er selber ruhig und wartet ab mit seinen Entscheidungen und mit seinen Meinungen an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen, fragt die lieber dreimal als einmal zu wenig. Und ich denke mal, genauso in dieser Wirtschaft, so befindet sich Autoschule jetzt, weil er weiß eine ganze Menge. Und ich denke mal, wie gesagt, wenn er auspacken würde, würden wir uns alle nicht mehr auf die Straße trauen.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass wir denn so Situationen bekommen können, wie Rumsfeld dir denn die Beweise für die Massenvernichtungsmittel im Irak als Argument aus der Tasche zieht?
Nö, noch dazu gab es die Massenvernichtungsmittel ja nun wirklich nicht.
Eben, eben, genau.
Und das wäre das Größte, was uns noch mal passieren könnte, dass sozusagen mit der Lüge da irgendwo eingeprescht wird und dass es im Endeffekt gar nicht wahr ist. Ja, sowas dürfte eigentlich gar nicht mal passieren. Und jetzt noch mal zu dem, was in London passiert. Ich meine, ich ziehe gut vor den Engländern, dass sie sich nicht so kleinkriegen lassen, wie die Amerikaner seien im 11. September nun mittlerweile vorbei. Und die Engländer, die sehen das total nüchtern, die ziehen das so durch, naja, die lösen das auf ihre feine englische Art und so.
Wie zum Beispiel bei den Brasilianer?
Unschuldige mit acht Schüssen hinten richten?
Na gut, den Amerikanern ist genau das selbe passiert. Die haben gesagt, wir holen den Tadamusi nach Hause und im Endeffekt hielten ihn auch nur ums Öl. Und die haben auch nicht gesagt, na gut, bei uns sind sehr, sehr viele Amerikaner umfliegen gekommen. Das eigene Volk hat mitgeletten und George Staviel Bush hat seine eigenen Leute, sein eigenes Volk total vernachlässigt. Er hat sich auch bei den Angehörigen überhaupt gar nicht gemeldet und wenn nur vormals vertreten lassen. Das ist auch nicht so die feine US-amerikanische Bürgerlichkeit, was man in so einem Moment einfach mal erwartet.
Wie ist es bei dir mit Kameraüberwachung? Fühlt sie dich da sicherer?
Wenn ich weiß, welchen Sinn und Zweck sie erfüllen sollen, ja. Aber ich denke mal, das ist nicht in einer Mass-Hilfstheorie wie Big Brother von Andy Moll aus atmen sollte, dass es halt zur Unterhaltung dient. Weil das ist das, worauf wir, glaube ich, ganz stark zusteuern, es einen Voyeurismus geben könnte.
Meinst du, dass sich Leute sich dran gewöhnen, sowieso auf Schritt und Tritt verfolgt zu werden und dann irgendwann auch jegliche Achtung vor der Privatsphäre von sich und von anderen verlieren?
Nee, denke ich mal nicht. Weil ich meine, wenn man sich abkatzen möchte, dann schafft man es auch. Also sozusagen, man darf es halt nur nicht falsch verstehen. Es ist alles für die Sicherheit. Und ich meine, sicher und die totale Sicherheit gibt es nicht. Das sagen auch alle Politiker und selbst am Flughafen. Wenn ich überlege, dann werde ich am Nacho Disco schärfer kontrolliert und würde mir so eine Kontrolle am Flughafen geben.
Das stimmt allerdings. Ja, ich weiß, die haben mich mal mit einem Nagelknipser zurückgeschickt und mit einem Laserman durchgelassen.
Und ich sage mal, um den Vergleich jetzt von meinen Segen, von Anstiegen auf USA und London, das ist natürlich ein beides ganz, ganz krasse Fälle, weil ich habe hier auch in Berlin sehr viele amerikanische Freunde und so. Und die sagen auch, das ist total grauenvoll. Natürlich, es ist nicht zu rechtfertigen, so Leute, die sind zwar schlau und hochintelligent, man darf sie noch nicht unterschätzen, aber die haben meiner Meinung nach einfach meinen Rat aus. Aber der ganz gravierende Unterschied, das darf man einfach mal nicht vergessen, für die Amerikaner war der 11. September das, was 1945 in Deutschland passiert ist. Sprich, es war für sie Krieg. Aber sowas...
Na ja, zumindest Krieg und seitdem sind sie halt total klein.
Zumindest Krieg auf ihrem eigenen Territorium. Das waren sie ja noch nicht mehr gewohnt.
Und von daher sag ich mal so, ich meine, die Engländer hätten genauso reagieren können. Aber sie machen es halt nicht. Und in dem Moment, wo sie das eben nicht tun, sagen sie, wir lassen uns von solchen Terroristen nicht einschüchtern. Und auch Anthony Blair macht das nicht. Und das spüre ich, das merke ich halt. Und ich finde diese Haltung einfach mal total klasse. Und auch hier in Deutschland ist es ja so, ein offenes Geheimnis ist. Schili meint, ja, hier sind sehr viele Schläfer und so weiter und so fort. Es werden ja auch nach den Voruntersuchungen gemacht. Aber ich denke mal, dass das A und O, was wir hier in Berlin und ganz Deutschland machen müssen, in Europa und auch in der Nationalseltsheit, lasst euch nicht vom Alltag wegkriegen. Und solange man diese Haltung bewahrt, versachsam, aber nicht halt durchgeknallt nach jeder Mülltüte, nur unbedingt gleich den Wachsdienst anzurufen und mal zu informieren, was könnte da drin sein, machen die eigentlich gar keine Fehler.
Danke, Sebastian. Und gute Fahrt noch. Die Briten, die haben es natürlich insofern gut, in Anführungszeichen, als dies gewohnt sind. Also die A-Hand-Schläge, die sind hier jetzt noch nicht so lange her, dass die Briten das schon verlernt hätten, auch damit umzugehen, so eine latente Bomben-Explosionsbedrohung zu haben, wobei die IAA auch nie Zivilisten attackiert hat, glaube ich, oder?
Die haben immer vorher gewarnt.
Genau. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Ihr seid eingeladen, anzurufen, mitzureden zwischen London und der Bundestagswahl.
Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand.
Das ist unser Thema heute Abend. Tobias aus Cottbus.
Und zwar, ich sag mal so, zu dieser Videoüberwachung, wir haben es in Cottbus mit den Straßenbahnen, wir haben es mit den Bussen.
Und mich stört es nicht.
Nutzt es denn, also sind die Busse und die Straßenbahnen weniger zerkratzt, zerstört, beschmiert?
Ja, also sag mal, diese Graffitis, die früher drin waren, sind weniger geworden. Die zerkratzten Scheiben gibt es nach wie vor. Aber es ist auch weniger geworden, halt Zerstörung, das ist einfach gar nichts mehr.
Also würdest du sagen, es hat tatsächlich was genutzt?
Ja, aber das ist die Graffitis, die ist nicht im, sondern außen. Und dafür, wenn jetzt seitdem das Video überwacht ist, werden seitdem mehr Haltestellenhäuschen zerklappt. Das wäre der Nachteil.
Dann müssen wir die eben auch noch im Video überwachen.
Ja, aber das würde uns schon nerven. Ich sag bloß immer, bei uns nach Sprengen einkaufen geht. Mir reicht es schon, wenn ich, sag ich mal, ein H&M überall Kameras hab, das reicht mir vollkommen aus. Weil ich würde mal in Ruhe einkaufen gehen, mit meinen Klamotten aussuchen und nicht ständig so einen Sicherheitsmensch mit auf die Finger gucken. Gut, ich sag mal so, es wird bestimmt geklaut. Klar, wie ich zur Auskunft, es wird ziemlich viel geklaut bei uns. Auch gerade in den Läden. Und dafür ist es wieder gut, aber dass man schon was mitten in der Stadt macht, geht dann genauso.
Es nervt einfach.
Ja, und auch aus dieser Internetspeicherung, wo du vorhin angesprochen hattest. Und zwar, ich mache nur mein Abilien, ich schreibe meine große Abschlussarbeit in Geschichte über das Thema Rechtsextrubus in Deutschland. Und da bin ich ja teilweise auch auf Seiten, sag ich mal, diese NPD-Homepage und solche Sachen, wo ich, sag ich mal, meinen Hintergrund ein bisschen herkriege. Ich sag mal so, wer es gespeichert wird, ich stehe es nicht ein. Ich mach nur meine Arbeit.
Wenn ich eine gute Arbeit hinkriege, da ist vielleicht eine Anzeige, darauf läuft es hinaus.
Dann solltest du dich beeilen mit der Arbeit, bevor dir alle gesperrt werden in Deutschland.
Genau.
Deswegen, also, meistens mach ich dann so, ich hab, ich weiß nicht, ob man das so einfach sagen darf, ich hab mittlerweile einen ausländischen Anbieter, einen Anbieter, der nicht auf dem Rechner, in Belgien, und ich denke mal, äh...
Du wählst dich mit einer belgischen Telefonnummer ein? Und das ist billiger, oder wie, oder ist das...
Also es kommt auf Dauer günstiger, ich will nichts zu machen wohl über T-Online. Was ich vorher hatte.
Das ist aber auch praktisch.
Nee, und da kommen wir an einige Seiten ran, die auch von deutschen Anbietern ausgesperrt sind.
Welche sind das zum Beispiel?
Also zum Beispiel, ich weiß von der DVU in Brandenburg, da ist eine Zweigseite, die bin ich über T-Online nie rangekommen, auch über andere deutsche Anbieter, und über den Belgier komm ich ohne Probleme rein. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. So ist es auch so, wenn diese Handyspeicherung ist, das würde mir genau so selten auf den Nerv gehen. Wenn ich ganz genau weiß, okay, ich kann vielleicht mal nicht in Ruhe meiner Freundin telefonieren, ohne dass mein Finger irgendjemand zuhört, dass irgendwo gespeichert wird, geht auch nicht.
Vor allem das Problem, das ich damit habe, ist einfach, du weißt immer gar nicht, wer sitzt denn da eigentlich und hat Zugang zu diesen Daten. Wenn ich jetzt, also zum Beispiel dieses hübsche, nachdem dann zum 1. April oder Mai hier in Deutschland das Bankgeheimnis praktisch abgeschafft wurde, frag ich mich auch, kann jetzt etwa jeder Ordnungsamtsmitarbeiter gucken, was für ein Konto ich habe und was auf diesem Konto drauf ist und wie sich da das Geld bewegt? Was ist, wenn ich jetzt den nächsten Ordnungsamtsmitarbeiter mal zur Sau mache, weil er mich schlecht behandelt hat, wird er mir dann irgendwie einen einschenken, weil er auf meine Daten zurückgreifen kann?
Das ist nicht nur das Ordnungsamt. Ich hab einen Kumpel, der ist ein Hacker, und er hat gefragt, ob er es mal machen kann, ausnahmsweise, um zu gucken, wie das jetzt ist mit diesen freigegebenen Daten, sag ich mal. Der ist ohne Probleme auf meine Kontodaten gekommen.
Auf deine eigenen?
Ja, auf meine.
Ach so, hast du ihm vorher das Passport gegeben oder nicht?
Der ist nur über die Homepage von der Sparkristin reingegangen. Da gibt es solche kleinen Programme und da war der drin. Das hat sogar mit der Kontodate von meinen Eltern geklappt, wo ich das Passport selber nicht wusste.
Sie sind beeindruckt.
Ja und das ist das Problem, das ich habe. Jeder kann da draufgucken, wer lustig ist.
Na so ganz einfach ist es ja nicht. Ich könnte das glaube ich nicht. Ich bin kein Hacker, ich bin nur Politikwissenschaftler. Das Problem, was ich dabei habe, ist halt, wenn repressive Behörden, also Polizei und ähnliche, draufgucken können. Was du vorher meintest, wenn du eine Arbeit schreibst, ich mache ja auch Forschung an der Uni, wenn man sich da mal Sachen anguckt, die vielleicht zweifelhaft sind, einfach aus dem Forschungsinteresse heraus, ob das Neonazi-Seiten sind oder anderes, wenn hinterher plötzlich die Polizei da mit Data-Mining-Systemen drüber läuft, dann halten die mich plötzlich auch für einen Nazi, bloß weil ich solche Seiten besuche. Und dann wird es natürlich heikel.
Ich erinnere mich dran, von einem Jahr ungefähr in der Telepolis gelesen zu haben, dass eine Frau unter anderem wegen ihrer Wishlist bei Amazon die Einreise in die USA verweigert wurde. Nur weil sie gesagt hat, dieses Buch würde ich gerne lesen.
Diese Programme, die man angesprochen hat, mit denen man diese Passwörter knacken kann, die gibt es vor allem im Internet. Also es gibt ein paar spezielle Seiten, wo man sich die Dinge einfach runterladen kann.
Dann müssen genau diese Seiten gesperrt werden. 0331 70 97 1 1 0.
Timon aus Berlin.
Hallo?
Timon, Timon.
Schade.
Timon will nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, es sah interessant aus, was hier auf dem Display steht. Zu Videoüberwachung und Anti-Amerikanismus wollte er was sagen. Timon, ruf bitte nochmal an. Entweder ist unser Telefon kaputt oder du bist inzwischen rausgeflogen und hast aufgelegt oder sonst irgendwie was. 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Hallo Nico.
Hallo.
Frank, Erik und Ralf.
An deine Gäste. Erstmal wollte ich was zur Videoüberwachung sagen. Meiner Meinung nach, und vielleicht ist das auch nicht nur meine Meinung, sondern auch die Meinung der Fritz Community, jedenfalls ein Teil davon, ist das Videoüberwachung auf den öffentlichen Plätzen doch auch mein Privatleben beeinträchtigt. Weil mein Privatleben befindet sich meiner Meinung nach nicht nur in meinen eigenen vier Wänden, sondern auch außerhalb der eigenen vier Wände. Hallo? Ich möchte nur mal ein Beispiel angeben. Also ich bin nicht homosexuell, aber stellt euch mal vor, da würden zwei Schwule oder zwei Lesben Hand in Hand, Küsschen und so weiter und so fort gefilmt werden. Die Leute, die diese Filme auswerten, die würden sich doch totlachen. Und wenn sie, also eben nicht, dass die jetzt denken, ich will die diskreditieren oder so. Die Homosexuellen im Gegenteil, also frei, die können von mir aus heiraten und so was. Aber die Leute, die diese Filme auswerten, die würden sich doch kranklachen. Und wenn diese Leute, wie soll ich sagen, nicht astrein sind, kopieren sie die Filme vielleicht noch ins Internet.
Es hat in den Vereinigten Staaten mal einen Fall gegeben, wo die Polizei von kleineren Gemeinden, da hingen auch Kameras an einer Stadt, die Schwulen warst, unter anderem überwacht haben und dann wurden anschließend Leute von den Polizisten erpresst. Das waren natürlich auch die schwarzen Schafe innerhalb der Polizei, aber es zeigt doch die Gefahr des Missbrauchs damals. Also da geht es nicht nur ums sich lustig, übersichtslustig machen, sondern eben auch.
Das geht ja noch weiter. Wo war das? Nordrhein-Westfalen und, ich glaube, Niedersachsen. Da ist Homosexualität ja offensichtlich sogar ein Straftat bestand. Zumindest was deren Polizeidatenbanken angeht.
Zumindest ein bemerkenswert in der Eingabemaske.
Bemerkenswert in der Eingabemaske, ja.
Eine Sache hätte ich aber noch. Und zwar ist mir in dem Blumen, der mir bis jetzt ganz gut gefällt, ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen, dass wir auch die Pflicht haben, an die Opfer zu denken.
Welche Opfer?
Die Opfer, die durch die Bombenanschläge zu Tode gekommen sind. Weil hier sehr viel damit darüber diskutiert wird, was die einzelnen Politiker, ob es nun Bush, Blair, na wie heißt der hier, was wollte ich Kinkle sagen? Chili, genau, was die dazu zu sagen haben. Aber mir fehlt da ein bisschen der Aspekt der Opfer.
Du meinst, dass...
Dass man damals ein bisschen mehr, wie soll ich sagen, samstmütiger mit umgeht.
Naja, aber ich sag mal, die Politiker, die von dir angesprochenen Politiker, die gehen ja nun nicht samstmütig mit denen um, die nicht zum Opfer geworden sind, sondern die machen die Überlebenden im Grunde zum Opfer. Und zwar zum Opfer von eingeschränkten Freiheitsrechten. Also, dass solcherlei Anschläge überhaupt irgendwelche Anschläge nicht zu billigen, nicht zu verstehen, nicht nachvollziehen und gar nichts, also überhaupt nicht hinnehmbar sind. Ich denke mal, das ist Konsens, das müssen wir nicht extra betonen.
Ich würde vielleicht noch ergänzen, dass es auch von den Politikern teilweise wirklich zynisch ist, wie die solche Anschläge und auch die Toten dabei instrumentalisieren und einfach nur für ihre Zwecke nutzen, indem sie dann Pläne aus der Schublade ziehen, die eigentlich schon seit Jahren von denen betrieben werden. Und das ist natürlich eine günstige Gelegenheit, das nochmal weiter durchzudrücken.
Das haben wir gerade in London gemerkt, bevor überhaupt feststand, was überhaupt wirklich passiert ist, waren sofort diese ganzen Vorschläge nach Videoüberwachung und mehr Maßnahmen auf dem Tisch.
Ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Abend und einen schönen Donnerstag morgen.
Tschüss.
Witz, Witz, Witz, Witz. Blue Moon.
Chaosradio 104 ist hier zwischen London und der Bundestagswahl und den zweiten Teil, den musst du wieder sagen, Frank?
Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand ist unser Thema.
Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand. Es geht um Videoüberwachung insbesondere, aber auch um Telefone, die abgehört werden und Verbindungsdaten, die gespeichert werden. Und eure Haltung dazu ist natürlich gefragt unter 0331 70 97 110. Denn im Chaosradio, da sollt ihr anrufen und mitreden. Das Chaosradio ist nämlich ein Blumen auf Fritz. Ihr könnt uns auch E-Mails schreiben. Wundert euch nicht, wenn da irgendwie eine Fehlermeldung zurückkommt. Ja, nur was an mich dann weitergeleitet wird von da aus oder so ähnlich, das funktioniert nicht mehr. Bisher hat Holger die mal ausgedruckt. Bisher hatten wir ein Euro-Jobber, die die Bildschirme abgeschrieben haben und dann losgeflitzt sind. Das hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert, aber das ist jetzt umgestellt worden auf digital, weil wir auch ein bisschen sparen müssen hier am Rundfunk Berlin Brandenburg. 0331779110 ist die Nummer der Fritz online und ihr seid herzlich angerufen, hier eingeladen, hier anzurufen. Ihr seid herzlich angerufen von uns mitzumachen. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, Sven aus Sonneberg.
Sven?
Warum, was ist das hier?
Ich weiß ja nicht, ist das mal wieder kaputt hier? Sven hört uns nicht, schade. Sven, ruf doch nochmal an. Timon von eben kann auch gerne nochmal anrufen. Irgendwas funktioniert hier, ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Hans?
Wunderbar. Schönen guten Abend.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Ja, und zwar wollte ich eigentlich auch mal loswerden, dass dieser ganze Sicherheitswahn, den Sie da jetzt entwickeln wollen, dass das auch ganz gewaltig nach hinten losgehen kann.
Auch schön gesagt, den Sicherheitswahn, den Sie entwickeln wollen. Ja, ein Sicherheitswahn-Labor.
Es würde ja darauf wieder auslaufen, dass wirklich neue Jobs, sag ich mal, jetzt zwar auch entstehen, aber diese Jobs nicht unbedingt sinnvoll wären. Weil wenn man sich überlegt, dass wirklich alles überwacht wird, Handy, Internet, Videokameras und was es nicht alles geben soll, und wo es sicherlich auch noch dann viel mehr geben wird, das können sicher dann auch zum Beispiel wieder die ganzen Terroristen und so weiter zunutze machen. Denn alles, was von Menschen nun mal entwickelt wird, kann auch von Menschen wieder gehackt werden. Und ich denke mal, das wäre ein ganz großes Problem.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, ob jetzt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich würde mir weniger Sorgen darum machen, dass jetzt einzelne Lead-Hack-Source hingehen und sich die Dinge unternagelreißen, oder irgendwie Daten unternagelreißen oder Fotos unternagelreißen. Ich würde mir viel mehr Sorgen darum machen, dass die Leute, die tatsächlich damit von Berufswegen zu tun haben die ganze Zeit, dass die irgendwann austicken, weil es sind eben auch nur Menschen. Nur weil es Polizisten sind, sind die nicht dagegen gefeiert, auch nur mal Scheiß im Kopf zu haben oder sowas.
Das ist richtig, aber wenn man sich halt mal überlegt, dass somit ja automatisch auch teilweise die Politiker und so weiter und den ganzen Staatsoberhaupten mitbeobachtet werden, weil auch die wohnen ja, sag ich mal, irgendwo. Und wenn man sich da wirklich reinhacken könnte, dann im Prinzip, was ja auch nur mal möglich ist, das wissen wir ja, das haben wir ja schon genügend Hackerattraktionen gezeigt, dass diese Leute auch gezielt verfolgt werden können und somit auch wieder sehr gezielte Anschläge gesetzt werden könnten.
Also du meinst, dass die ganzen Kameras im Regierungsviertel ganz praktisch sind, weil man da dann viel gezielter schießen kann?
Unter anderem, ja. Oder wie gesagt auch per Handyüberwachung. Wo ist denn unser Schröder jetzt gerade? Okay, da läuft er gerade lang auf der Straße. So nach dem Motto, dann schickt doch mal jemanden vorbei.
So könnte es ja dann kommen.
Ich fände das ohnehin eine sehr schöne Gegenmaßnahme, wenn man sowieso solche Datenbanken pflegen würde. Das kann man ja auch sicherlich über verschiedene Protokolle machen, also sowohl Audio als auch Video als auch schriftlich. Einfach Datenbanken zu pflegen, wo eben unsere Politiker sich gerade aufhalten und was sie gerade tun. Fände ich ganz lustig.
Kennzeichnerkennung eignet sich wunderbar dafür.
Da würden sie vielleicht mal merken, was sie da vorhaben.
Oder man macht gleich die ganzen Überwachungsdatenbanken open source. Wie Wikipedia oder sonst was und stellt sie ins Netz für jeden zu überführen. Jede Überwachungskamera zur Webcam.
Ich denke mal, wie gesagt, da sollte man mal wirklich sich Gedanken drüber machen, weil wie gesagt, diese ganzen Sicherheitssysteme, die hier entwickelt wurden, wurden alle, denke ich mal, also mir wäre jetzt keins bekannt, sei es jetzt FBI, CIA, auch die haben wahnsinnige Sicherheitssysteme, aber sie haben halt auch immer wieder ihre Löcher drinnen. Und ich denke mal, da sollte man sich ganz sanfte, sage ich mal, rantasten, ob man das wirklich so dringend braucht und vor allem, in welchen Maßen man diese Sicherheit braucht, beziehungsweise sinnvoll nutzen kann.
Danke, Hans.
Und guten Abend, Anatol.
Hi, grüß dich, Holger. Folgendes, also diese Videoüberwachung, ich glaube, wenn sie nicht lächendeckend gemacht würde, und das würde ich ja sehr kritisch betrachten, die würde ja nur zur Verschiebung der Probleme führen. Also das heißt, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ich habe einen Schwerpunkt mit Kriminalität, da hauen wir jetzt ein paar Videokameras hin, dann würden die Protagonisten ja letztendlich verschwinden. Die würden sich dann eine neue Lokalität suchen. Das sieht man ja, wenn du mit einer Kamera, mit einem Fernsehteam durch so einen Park gehst, wo lauter Drogentypen rumhängen, die werden ja dann nicht in die Kamera winken, sondern die gehen dann einfach laufen. Und das funktioniert also nur flächendeckend. Und flächendeckend würde ich das also, wie gesagt, sehr kritisch betrachten, weil dann hat man überhaupt keine Privatsphäre mehr.
Oder?
Der Erik, der hat dazu geforscht. Ist es so, dass sie weglaufen oder verhinderts Verbrechen?
Also es hängt sehr stark davon ab, wo und wie Videoüberwachung gemacht wird. Aber ich meine, wenn wir jetzt mal nicht über Terroristen reden, sondern über halt wirklich das Beispiel, was angesprochen wurde, Drogenkriminalität, Beschaffungskriminalität oder so, da ist es ganz klar, dass es verdrängt wird. Das sagt auch die Polizei selbst. Auch wenn häufig immer wieder behauptet wird, Kriminalität würde nicht verdrängt werden, also Herr Schönbohm sagte das ja immer, dann muss man sich auch angucken, wie diese Untersuchungen gemacht werden. Und einfach nur in den Nachbargebieten von Erkner, also von dem Bahnhof von Erkner, wo überwacht wird, zu gucken, dann praktisch die benachbarten Orte sich anzugucken ist ein bisschen dürftig, weil man setzt sich in Erkner einfach in die S-Bahn und fährt in die Innenstadt und verübt dann da halt das, was man machen will. Also auch wenn behauptet wird, Kriminalität wird nicht verdrängt, das hätten irgendwelche Untersuchungen gezeigt, ist das ein relativ fragwürdiges Ergebnis.
Aber was ich eben noch gehört habe, hier mit dem Handy, die Story oder mit dem Kennzeichen Politiker überwachen, funktioniert nicht, weil Politiker alle gesperrte Kennzeichen haben. Das heißt, sie sind beim Bundeskraftverdammt gesperrt. Da kommt noch nicht mal die normale Polizei dran.
Aber irgendwer wird doch irgendwann mal beobachten, wie irgendein Politiker in irgendein Auto steigt.
Ja, aber das Kennzeichen ist beim Bundeskraftverdammt gesperrt. Das heißt, das nennt man Kennzeichenssperre. Paragraph 41, Straßenverkehrsgesetz, glaube ich. Und das heißt, ein normaler Schupo-Beamter kommt gar nicht an die Daten ran.
Muss er ja gar nicht. Wenn ich morgen sehe, wie Otto Schillen in ein Auto einst, da kann ich mir schnell das Kennzeichen aufschreiben, packt das bei mir ins Blog und sage so, wenn ihr das nächste Mal einen grünen VW Jetta...
Ja, die fahren ja alle mit B-Strich 7.0 und drei weiteren Ziffern. Die haben ja immer jeden Tag andere Kennzeichen. Das sind alles gesperrte Kennzeichen, kann man ja vergessen. Und die Handynummern, die sind ja auch alle geheim.
Das wäre aber toll, wenn man mal beim Kanzler anrufen könnte.
Beim Kanzler? Ja, 56.0 glaube ich.
Da habe ich überhaupt nicht noch die Bonnernummer, die ich im Kopf habe.
Dann geht er nicht persönlich ran und sagt, Schröder.
Ist es tatsächlich so, dass Sie die Kennzeichen jeden Tag wechseln?
Kanzler, Schröder.
Dann würde unser schönes Data-Mining-Projekt gar nicht funktionieren.
Naja, es ist so, die haben ja auch verschiedene Autos. Ich meine, ich habe Schröder letztens in einem BMW gesehen. Obwohl, der heißt, er würde VW, wie heißt es jetzt? VATON, ja genau, fahren. Letztens sind wir mit einem BMW gefahren.
Vielleicht war sein VW gerade in einer Werkstattinspektion.
Ich höre BMW bringen, mal Werkzeug.
Oder er wollte Sympathiepunkte in Bayern.
Moment mal, was für ein Data-Mining-Projekt, Frank.
Die Idee ist, mit dieser Kennzeichenerkennung, wie sie auch an den Mautbrücken ist, sich einfach mal eine Woche oder zwei Wochen in Berlin an die Straßen zu stellen, an ein paar mankante Punkte, einfach mal Kennzeichen zu sammeln und die in eine Datenbank reinlaufen zu lassen und dann mal gucken, welche Autos wo auftauchen. Interessante Start-Under-Auto wären zum Beispiel vor dem Bundestag, vor der Fahrbereitschaft und an zwei, drei stadtbekannten Puffs und dann schauen wir mal weiter.
Da hättest du mal was sagen müssen. Ich bin letzte Woche in Charlottenburg gerade ausgesucht. Bei mir um die Ecke war ein stadtbekannter Puff. Und da standen nachts auch immer Autos davor, bei denen ich mir sicher sein konnte, dass die nicht irgendwelchen normalen Leuten gehören.
Das hört sich ja gut an.
Wartende Chauffeure und so.
Aber was ich noch sagen muss, ein konkreter Fall, wenn es drauf ankommt, kann es ja passieren, dass die Videodaten plötzlich verschwinden. Also, soll ich mal einen konkreten Fall nennen?
Ja natürlich.
Also, ich weiß ja nicht, vielleicht liest du Tagesspiegel oder so was oder Berliner Zeitung? Manchmal. Ja, also stand ja gestern oder vorgestern der Artikel drin über die Story. Ich war ja vor Gesicht. Ja, ja, ich hab ja vor zwei Jahren BVG-Kontrolleure gefilmt.
Du hast vor zwei Jahren BVG-Kontrolleure gefilmt? Okay, Anna, also du hast vor zwei Jahren BVG-Kontrolleure gefilmt. Warum?
Das war, weil ich einfach eine Kontroverse gefilmt habe zwischen den Kontrolleuren und den...
In dem Fall erinnere ich mich.
Moment, Moment, Moment. War das Zufall? Also war das zufälligerweise ein Video?
Ich kam mit der Kamera vorbei und wollte eigentlich woanders hinfahren. Und der Dialog war ziemlich interessant. Das war eine spanisch sprechende Frau, die hat sich aber dann als Deutsche entpuppt. Also die wollte die Kontrolleure wahrscheinlich in die Öre führen und so tun, als ob sie nur eine Ausländerin wäre und sich so sozusagen entziehen. Und das Lustige war, dass der eine Kontrolleur aber auch spanisch konnte. Ja ja, und dann war die Frau erstmal perplex. Dann kam es zu einer kontroverse vielen Verbalinjurien zwischen einem weiteren schmutzmaßlichen Schwarzfahrer und den Kontrolleuren. Und dann habe ich natürlich, wie man das so macht, die Kamera direkt draufgehalten. Und die meinten dann, ich soll die Kamera ausschalten, habe ich dann auch gemacht. Und jetzt fiel ich aber in den Mittelpunkt deren Konzentration. Und sie wollten mein Filmmaterial haben. Ich habe dann halt Nein gesagt, habe auch meinen Presserausweis gezeigt. Und hat sie alles nicht interessiert, dann haben sie mich halt über den Bahnhof getragen, um es mal höflich auszudrücken. Betragen?
Moment mal, die sind handgreiflich geworden?
Ja natürlich. Es kam auch ein Polizeieinsatz, war ja ein großer Skandal vor zwei Jahren. Die sind ja auch vorläufig festgenommen worden.
Ja du oder die?
Die waren zivilfahrende und informierte Beamte, ich glaube vom Abschnitt 31. Und auf jeden Fall angeblich hat BVG kein Filmmaterial und auch die zwei Schwarzfahrer, die ja erfasst worden sind, hat die BVG angeblich plötzlich nicht mehr die Daten gehabt, weil die ja Tatsäugen waren. Und das Lustige ist, diese Kontrolleure haben dann ausgesagt, ich hätte sie angegriffen und ihre Geweittat sei Notwehr gewesen. Und das Lustige, in Anführungszeichen, am Montag stand ich vor Gericht wegen Körperverletzung. Die Story findest du im Tagespiegel.de.
Was war das Urteil?
Das Lustige ist, ich sag schon zu oft lustig, ist verschoben worden, weil ein paar Kontrolleure sind erst gar nicht aufgekreuzt, und ich weiß auch nicht, warum die Angst vor dem Gericht haben. Es ist verschoben worden. Auf den 26. September, ich glaube um 12.30 Uhr. 26. September, 12.30 Uhr. Und das Krasse ist, ich hab damals einen Notruf abgegeben, dass ich hier auf dem Rosa-Lupfenburg-Platz stehe und mich Kontrolleure nicht gehen lassen wollen. Und während ich mit den Polizeibeamten in der Leitstelle telefoniere, greifen die mich an. Also deren Angriff ist sogar auf Notrufmitschnitt. Und jetzt kommt der Hammer. Und wenn die jetzt sagen, hier Notwehr, Notwehr ist ja eigentlich setzt voraus einen gegenwärtigen rechtswidrigen Angriff. Und da müsste ja auf den Notrufmitschnitt, also die haben mich erst so 30 Sekunden, nachdem ich mit den Beamten schon telefoniere, angegriffen, also müsste man ja in diesen ersten 30 Sekunden hören, Herr Polizeimeister, bitte kommen Sie, ach Moment mal, ich muss mal kurz diese Kontrolleure schlagen.
Warten Sie mal kurz.
Aber da hört man nichts von, komischerweise. Und ich frage mich echt, was aus unserer Staatsanwaltschaft geworden ist. Ich meine, wenn einer sich bei der Polizei bewirbt, dann muss er erstmal einen Test auf logisches Denken machen. Diese Story, wie wenn die Fensterscheiben auf der Straße liegen, dann ist der Einbruch ja nicht geschehen, sondern von innen ist das Fenster eingeschlagen worden. Dann muss man so einen Logiktest machen. Das muss bei der Staatsanwaltschaft offenbar nicht der Fall sein. Weil wenn ich ein Notrufprotokoll lese, und da steht drin, dass man deutlich hört, wie die einen angreifen, dann kann ja gar keine Notwehr gegeben sein.
Hat denn irgendwer sich nochmal zu der Frage, darfst du überhaupt Kontrollettis filmen, während sie ihre Arbeit nachgehen, oder darfst du das nicht? Hat sich da nochmal jemand dazu geäußert, oder ist jetzt nur noch Körperverletzung?
Die haben auch später die Polizei angerufen. Nach meinem Notruf haben die angerufen bei der Polizei, sie sollen sofort kommen, weil hier jemand filmt. Das ist aber keine Straftat, das haben wir rechtlich prüfen lassen. Es ist nur verboten, mit grellem Scheinwerferlicht zu filmen. Die Kamera hatte aber keinen Scheinwerfer, lustigerweise. Ich habe mir bestätigen lassen, dass genau an dieser Kamera überhaupt kein Scheinwerfer angebracht werden kann.
Du sagtest, dass da Aufzeichnungen verschwunden worden sind.
Ich rede jetzt von der BVG-Kamera.
Aber die zeichnen derzeit noch nicht auf. Also wenn du da hättest aufgezeichnet werden wollen, hättest du nicht die Polizei anrufen sollen, sondern diese komischen Notrufsäulen betätigen. Ist schon klar, nur als Trip für Leute, die vielleicht in ähnliche Situationen warten.
Das heißt, Notruftaste drücken, in dem Moment läuft die Kamera.
Das ändert sich jetzt mit diesem Modellprojekt.
Ja, aber komisch ist jedenfalls, dass sie auch nicht die Daten dieser zwei Schwarzfahrer haben. Also das ist schon merkwürdig, soweit ich weiß, wenn die ein Jahr gespeichert.
Das ist echt krass. 26. September sagst du?
Ja, um 12.30 Uhr im Amtsgericht Tiergarten, Turmstraße 91.
Vielleicht kommen jetzt genug Leute vorbei. Ich glaube der Eintritt ist frei?
Der Eintritt ist frei, es ist öffentlich.
Wird man da gefilmt? Wie bitte? Wird man da gefilmt, wenn man da zum Gericht geht?
Ja, die Kamera musst du am Eingang abgeben, Laptop musst du auch abgeben, alles, Handys auch abgeben. Aber du kriegst eine Quittung.
Und hinkommen wir alle mit der U5?
Ich glaube die U9, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist die U9-Richtung aus Nürnberg.
Ich hab so viel Angst vor...
Aber da kann man ja mal ein paar Kontrolleure fragen.
Aber die erkennt man doch nicht.
Die Protagonisten, die damals aktiv waren, die sahen ja aus, als ob die gerade aus der Türsteherszene kamen.
Ach so echt, so Brandenburger Rechtsradikale?
Nee, nicht unbedingt. Es war auch ein Jugoslave dabei. Also mit serbischen Namen. Das nicht. Aber sie sehen halt so bullig aus. Aber es hat sich, glaube ich, das muss ich auch sagen, ich will jetzt die BVG jetzt nicht mies machen.
Das ist ja auch nicht die BVG-Miesmachsendung hier.
Es hat sich aber auch einiges getan. Also wenn ich jetzt ab und zu mit der BVG schon mal fahre, dann sehe ich auch, die Kontrolleure machen jetzt einen sympathischeren Eindruck.
Echt?
Mir ist das wirklich mal passiert. Ich bin in die U-Bahn eingestiegen und habe gedacht, mein Gott, schon hier ist so ein scheiß Alkoholiker, der in der Ecke sitzt. Und dann springt der Typ auf, als wäre der Zug los, für immer die Fahrausweise, bitte.
Danach bin ich nie wieder schwarz gefahren.
Anatol, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ja, und übrigens, ich hab noch mal nachgeguckt wegen der Ellipse.
Was?
Wir haben auch mal vor ein paar Wochen telefoniert, wegen der Ellipse, weißt du noch, mit dem Lückenfüller, wo du meintest, die Ellipse sei aus der Mathematik.
Du erwischst mich gerade auf einem völlig falschen Fuß, Anatol, und das gehört auch jetzt nicht in. Schick mir eine Mail. Eigentlich geht es hier nämlich um Videoüberwachung, beziehungsweise, ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben, Frank, Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand zwischen London und der Bundestagswahl. Und wir haben immer noch ein paar Anrufer in der Leitung. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Und wir schalten live nach Meerbusch. Uuuuh. Ja, wir sagen dir auch nichts.
Nee, nur weil der Ton ändert sich ja im 40er und so.
Ich kann ein bisschen Musik unterlegen. Soll ich mal machen?
Zum Thema Videoüberwachung wollte ich sagen, es gibt bei flickr.com, kennt man ja diese Foto-Community, da gibt es eine Group, die heißt 1984 als Zahl. Und da gibt es im Moment 369 Fotos von Videokameras, von Überwachungskameras, die... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es jetzt irgendwie in der Deutsch wird, ne, es ist international. Ja, aus Supermärkten von Straßen, Kreuzungen, was auch immer.
Das ist sozusagen eine Sammlung der technischen Gerätschaften, die da eingesetzt werden, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ja.
Oder sind das jetzt Bilder, quasi Mitschnitte davon, von den Kameras?
Nein, nein, das sind Bilder, auf denen die Kameras abgebildet sind.
Sagen die Metaebene quasi.
Das ist irgendwie ganz interessant, vor allen Dingen ist mir dabei aufgefallen, dass eigentlich so der Großteil der Kameras, die ich da gesehen habe, also dass ich die eigentlich gerechtfertigt finde, weil das eigentlich, ich weiß nicht, die sind meistens in Supermärkten oder in irgendwelchen Geschäften.
Entschuldige, wie heißt das Tag? 1984?
Da steht rechts neben Tag.
Da muss ich wieder hier...
Findest du es denn generell gerechtfertigt, dass Kameras an welchen Orten auch immer hängen? Also ich meine, wo ist für dich da die Grenze?
Ja, das ist echt schwierig. Also ich bin da im Moment auch ein bisschen am Überlegen, weil... Also eigentlich kann ich niemanden verübeln, wenn er in seinem eigenen Geschäft eine Kamera aufstellt, um zu verhindern, dass da irgendwie geklaut wird. Weil das ist ja auch der Grund, warum eine Kamera zum Beispiel im Supermarkt hängt. Die machen das ja nicht um...
Bloß, dass es gegen das Klauen irgendwas bringt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es was bringt, aber...
Also es wird dann halt in der Ecke geklaut, wo keine Kamera ist. Es wird dann halt in der Ecke geklaut, wo keine Kamera ist.
Wahrscheinlich. Dann weiß ich nicht, wie das da ist. An öffentlichen Plätzen und so, da hab ich das natürlich auch nicht so gern und mich nervt das natürlich auch und so. Aber die Gefahren, die dadurch entstehen, die sind eigentlich bei den meisten Kameras nicht unbedingt gegeben.
Aber was würdest du sagen, wenn zum Beispiel diverse Supermarkte in deiner Umgegend größtenteils in irgendeine Sicherheitszentrale von einem privaten Dienst aufgeschaltet sind?
Also eigentlich ist mir persönlich ziemlich egal, wer das sieht. Wer meine Bilder sieht. Die Gefahren, die ich bei Kameraüberwachung sehe, sind eigentlich zwei. Zuerst mal natürlich, wenn überall an öffentlichen Plätzen Kameras stehen, dadurch wird irgendwie diese Unschuldvermutung aufgeweicht. Also so weit sind wir ja jetzt schon, dass die meisten Leute irgendwie sagen, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen und deswegen ist es mir egal, wenn ich gefilmt werde. Und im Gegenzug, wenn man dann darauf besteht, nicht gefilmt zu werden, dann muss man ja was zu verbergen haben. Und das ist ja eigentlich nicht Sinn der Sache. Normalerweise sollte man ja davon ausgehen, dass prinzipiell jeder unschuldig ist.
Also die Unschuldsvermutung gilt ja eigentlich auch.
Auf der Supermarkt sollte davon ausgehen. Ich finde Kameras im Supermarkt auch nicht wirklich schön. Ich fühle mich da auch ein bisschen... Ich fühle mich da auch nicht unbedingt wohl, wenn davon ausgegangen wird, dass ich ein potenzieller Dieb bin.
Könntest du dir denn manchmal den Spaß damit? Also dich absichtlich auffällig verhalten?
Das ist die zweite Gefahr, die ich bei Kameras sehe. Dass dadurch irgendwie das Verhalten der Leute so gleich geschaltet wird. Es gibt ja auch solche Dinge. Auf dem Parkplatz steht eine Überwachungskamera. Und dann gibt es irgendwie angemessenes Verhalten und irgendwie nicht angemessenes Verhalten auf einem Parkplatz. Angemessen ist halt, man geht hin und schließt sein Auto auf und fährt weg. Und dann gibt es halt auch Sachen, die man einfach nicht tut auf dem Parkplatz.
Gerade die sollte man auch dann immer tun, ne?
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gesehen. Das ist auch schon ziemlich weit fortgeschritten eigentlich, dass es irgendwie so ein standardisiertes Verhalten gibt, was man tun kann und was nicht.
Das sehe ich halt als ganz, ganz großes Problem, dass genau dieses standardisierte Verhalten, das ist, was diese Kameras letztendlich bewirken. Das heißt, wir versuchen uns halt alle enorm konform zu verhalten und bloß ja nichts, irgendwas anderes zu machen, weil das könnte uns ja irgendwelchen Ärger einbringen.
Genau, und das ist eigentlich so das Hauptproblem gar nicht mal unbedingt. Mir ist es im Prinzip, meine persönliche Einstellung ist, mir ist es eigentlich egal, ob irgend ein Idioter vor der Kamera sieht, wie ich da irgendwie über die Straße gehe. Es geht halt wirklich nur darum, dass ja, dass man eben sonst sich verdächtig macht, sobald man sich nicht so verhält, wie man das eigentlich sollte an bestimmten Orten. Und das ist ja auch schon so. Also ich weiß nicht, ich werde eigentlich regelmäßig hier von der Polizei angehalten. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht gehe ich irgendwie zur falschen Uhrzeit raus, vielleicht sehe ich irgendwie auffällig aus oder so.
Na, siehst du denn auffällig aus? Also bist du anders gekleidet? Hast du eine wundersame Frisur?
Ja eigentlich nicht. Also ich meine, es kommt ab und zu mal vor, dass man sich dann mit einem Freund so nachts um fünf etwas verpeilt mit einem Laptop auf dem Schoß im Auto sitzt oder so. Aber gar nicht unbedingt, was verbotenes macht.
Ja, aber das verstehen sie ja nicht. Und hinterher steht bei Spiegel Online dann wieder, dass jemand ein WLAN gehackt hätte.
Ja, nee, auch andere Sachen.
Man muss nur irgendwie zur falschen Uhrzeit unterwegs sein oder irgendwie gerade irgendwie Spaß gehabt haben mit irgendwas, was nicht unbedingt normal ist. Weil normalerweise geht man halt nicht nachts raus. Und ja, und das führt dann schon dazu, dass man da angehalten wird. Und die Leute können es auch absolut nicht verstehen. Das ist halt ein Verhalten, was nicht normal ist. Ja, das ist irgendwie das, was dadurch passiert. Und das ist eigentlich das eigentlich Gefährliche. Deswegen finde ich Überwachungskameras sollte man einfach mal ganz lassen. Außer wenn jetzt einer meint, ich will niemanden verbieten, in seinem eigenen Laden da irgendwie eine Kamera hinzustellen. Also wenn ich selbst einen Laden hätte, weiß ich nicht, ob ich da eine Kamera hätte.
Ich hab in der Tanke gearbeitet, da war so eine Kamera, um mich zu überwachen.
Damit ich keine, weiß nicht, Schritten klaue oder was.
Sieht man ja dann auch irgendwie im Fernsehen immer auf RTL und so. Gibt ja solche Videos, wo dann Leute irgendwie in einen Kaffee pinkeln oder so.
Ich guck sowas nicht. Don, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, gute Nacht.
Und gute Nacht, tschüss. Michael aus Freiburg ist dran. Du bist drauf, je nachdem, was du genommen hast.
Also, eine Art Vernagung möchte ich mal einflechten. Diese ganze Überwachungsgeschichte, die jetzt auch immer wieder angesprochen wurde, ist einfach auch ein Eingriff in die ganz normalen bürgerlichen Grundrechte. Und ich bin durchaus nicht der Meinung, dass die irgendwie ein erhöhtes Sicherheitsgefühl oder irgendso was bringen. Also ich bin jetzt vor kurzem in Norwegen gewesen und muss sagen, dort habe ich keine einzige Kamera gesehen und mein Sicherheitsgefühl war dort wesentlich höher. Das ist aber bloß eine Vorbemerkung. Eigentlich wollte ich zu was anderem noch was sagen. Und zwar ist vorhin diese Geschichte, deswegen hatte ich angerufen...
Entschuldigung, gibt es tatsächlich in Norwegen keine Kameras oder sind sie dir nur nicht aufgefallen?
Also sagen wir mal so, ich habe einen großen Bogen um die ganz großen Städte gemacht, aber in den kleineren Städten habe ich sowas nicht gesehen.
In Oslo gibt es eine ganze Menge Kameras, da gibt es auch einen öffnen.
Ja gut, aber um Oslo habe ich auch einen Bogen gemacht.
Aber ich schätze mal, wenn du in deutsche Kleinstädte gehst oder in deutsche Dörfer wirst du eine ähnliche Situation haben.
Ja, aber da sind sie ja auch schon in Läden, aber dort habe ich es eben auch in Läden nicht gesehen. Es ist einfach auch dieses permanente Angstgefühl nicht da. Also und dieses Unsicherheitsgefühl. Also dort ist es ja auch so, dass eigentlich eine ähnliche Situation ist. Ich weiß nicht, kennt ihr den Michael-Moor-Film Bowling for Columbine? Sicher, ja. Dort ist ja eigentlich eine Geschichte, dieser Unterschied zwischen Kanada und USA sehr schön rausgearbeitet worden. Und ähnliches ist eigentlich auch in Norwegen. Dort schließt keiner ein Haus ab. Dort ist nicht dieses permanente Angstgefühl da. Und man merkt eigentlich, es scheint auch überhaupt wesentlich weniger zu passieren, als beispielsweise schon im Nachbarland Schweden von Deutschland ganz zu schweigen. Und ich denke mal, die Frage fängt wirklich da an, wo im Prinzip die Politik selber anfängt Hysterie zu machen. Da bin ich eigentlich schon bei dem Thema, wo ich hinwollte, nämlich diese ganze Geschichte der Instrumentalisierung und eben auch der Instrumentalisierung von Terrorgeschichten.
Was wollen die Politiker damit genau instrumentalisieren? Welchen Vorteil versprechen sie sich davon, deiner Meinung nach?
Na, eigentlich sind, wenn ich mir das angucke, eigentlich sind die Politiker ja nichts anderes als ausführende Organe einer Machtelite. Nicht mehr und nicht weniger. Und es geht einfach wirklich um Durchsetzung und Kontrolle und Erhaltung von Macht. Und natürlich kann ich Macht besonders gut erhalten, wenn ich Leute gut kontrollieren kann. Das ist eigentlich, ob das nun von Orwell beschrieben wurde in Romanform oder auch in verschiedenen Studien belegt wurde. Also es ist einfach so. Und eigentlich wird nichts anderes gemacht. Und die Geschichte ist einfach, auch bei dieser ganzen Terrorismusfrage und auch bei diesen Schürungen von Ängsten, wo dann plötzlich wieder neue sogenannte Sicherheitspakete auf den Tisch gelegt werden. Das haben wir ja eigentlich in Deutschland gerade in den letzten Jahren ein paar Mal erlebt. Wo dann Sachen dann aus dem Schreibtisch gekramt wurden, die dann schon wirklich alles anhaltslustig waren. Und es geht eigentlich wirklich nur darum, Grundrechte einzuschränken, um wirklich dort die Macht über die Bevölkerung und über die Menschen im Prinzip zu perfektionieren und zu erhöhen.
Vielen Dank Michael, wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Und eine gute Nacht noch.
Achso, dann mach noch schnell.
Ja gut, ich wollte nämlich zu diesem Terrorismus, denn eigentlich ist immer wieder die Frage, was ist eigentlich Terrorismus? Eigentlich geht es ja darum, dass unbeteiligte Dritte in die Auseinandersetzung von Zweien reingezogen werden und dort benutzt werden. Und es ist ja beispielsweise eben so, dass diese Geschichten sich auch wunderbar dann benutzen lassen. Und wenn du das Beispiel USA zum Beispiel hast, die Regierung Bush konnte ja bis jetzt noch mit keinem einzigen Argument wirkungsvoll entkräften, dass sie in die Anschläge vom September nicht selber verwickelt gewesen ist.
Das ist aber genauso gut, als würdest du sagen, niemand kann entkräften, dass es nicht doch rosa Elefanten irgendwo im Universum gibt. Das ist eine logische Unmöglichkeit, die du da gerade forderst. Es tut mir leid, weil ich dir da in die Parade fahren muss. Doch, doch, du kannst nicht nachweisen, dass irgendetwas nicht existiert. Und genau das verlangst du aber, was die US-Regierung tun soll.
Gut, aber letztendlich, sie waren die einzigen Nutznieser.
Ja, gut, Plausibilität, entschuldige, aber da gerätsch ich rein. Plausibilität ist kein Indiz.
Gut, das ist natürlich richtig, daher gebe ich dir recht.
Das ist so einfach, darfst du das nicht machen, jetzt müssen wir wirklich Nachrichten machen.
Aber Praxis ist natürlich eins, dass Terror instrumentalisiert worden ist, weil beispielsweise die IRA oder auch die Baskische Widerstandsorganisation genannt wurde. Es gibt doch einen Unterschied eben zu denen, zum Beispiel was in London passiert ist. Das beispielsweise gewarnt wurde und beispielsweise die IRA hat bei ihren Anschlägen in London rechtzeitig gewarnt. Und dort ist zum Beispiel seitens der Polizei absichtlich nicht evakuiert worden, um im Prinzip absichtlich Bevölkerungsverluste zu haben, die man dann wieder benutzen kann. Und da fragt man sich natürlich, wer ist da an der Stelle eigentlich der Terrorist? Und die Geschichte ist auch zum Beispiel bei den Roten Brigaden, die sind ja zum Beispiel, wo dann anfingen, deren Anschläge richtig blutig zu werden. Da stellt sich dann im Nachhinein raus, dass sie vom italienischen Geimendienst gesteuert wurden.
Nichtsdestotrotz schweifen wir gerade viel zu weit ab und wir müssen Nachrichten machen, Michael. Schönen Abend noch.
Ja, danke.
Wenn Fritz in Fürstenwalde, dann 101, 5.
Fünf nach halb zwölf. Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht erwarten uns mal mehr, mal weniger Wolken. Teilweise regnet es, die Tiefstemperaturen liegen zwischen 18 und 14 Grad. Morgen bleibt es meistens wolkig und es gibt einzelne Schauer und Gewitter. Nur im Süden Brandenburgs ist es weitgehende Heiter. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 30 bis 35 Grad. Und die Meldungen steigen mit Matthias Gerkhoff.
In Ostdeutschland droht in den kommenden 15 Jahren ein massiver Stellenverlust. Laut einer Studie der Bundesagentur für Arbeit könnten bis zu eine Million Jobs verloren gehen. Die Aussichten seien damit noch schlechter als vor Jahren angenommen, heißt es. Im größten Kinderschinderprozess Frankreichs hat ein Gericht die Urteile gesprochen. Die Richter verhängten hohe Haftstrafen. Die über 60 Täter hatten insgesamt 45 Kinder missbraucht. Das jüngste Opfer war sechs Monate alt. Die britischen Sicherheitsbehörden haben am Abend die Festnahme eines der vier verhinderten Selbstmordattentäter vom vergangenen Donnerstag bestätigt. Da behandelt es sich um einen 24-jährigen Somalier. Nach den anderen drei Tätern wird weiterhin gefadet. Die vorbeugende Telefonüberwachung in Niedersachsen ist verfassungswidrig. Das hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden. Niedersachsen wollte der Polizei ermöglichen, ohne konkreten Tatverdacht Telefongespräche abzuhören. Zum Fußball im Liga-Pokal schlug der FC Schalke 04 Werder Bremen 2 zu 1. Der Verkehr auf Fritzer 2 bedient eine Ringrichtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Brandenburg an der Havel und Berlin ist die Ausfahrt gesperrt. Hier ist ein LKW direkt an der Anstoßstelle liegen geblieben. Ansonsten wünschen wir gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias Kerkhoff, gleich sieben Minuten nach halb zwölf.
Fritz, eine Produktion des RBB. Die Popkom kommt auch dieses Jahr nach Berlin. Und Fritz, ist das Radio zur Popkom? Vom 14. bis 16. September. Dreieste Musik, Fritz.
Wir haben eine Rechtsgrundlage, dass wir nicht Plätze überwachen, sondern eine Rechtsgrundlage, dass wir gefährdete Objekte überwachen können. Das bringt was bei Tankstellen oder, oder, oder. Da haben wir auch Erfolge damit. Aber die Vorstellung, ich würde hier alle Straßen und Plätze Video überwachen lassen und damit hätte ich etwas für die Sicherheit getan, ist irisch.
Erhard Klotting, der Innensenator von Berlin zur Kameraüberwachung in der Bundeshauptstadt. Er hat das Chaosradio 104, Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand. Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand ist unser Thema. Es geht im Wesentlichen um Kameraüberwachung, weil das auch gerade das große Thema in der Politik ist. 0331 70 97 1 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline, unter der ihr eingeladen seid mitzudiskutieren und angerufen hat. Die Susi aus Placo. Moment, halt da. Susi?
Ja, ich wollte sagen, dass es total schwachsinnig ist, also mit den Kameras, weil ich denke immer viele können sich da aus dem Internet in die Kameras vielleicht dann rein, sag ich mal, hacken und das da mit überwachen und aber das ist doch toll, denn gucken mehr Menschen mit.
Also ich meine, es ist doch viel sicherer dadurch.
Dann kann man es doch gleich an Endemol verkaufen, macht die Polizei noch Geld mit.
Die Kontakte haben sie ja schon, weil sie sowieso die Produzenten mit Koks versorgen. Nein, das war nur ein Scherz, liebe Polizei.
Und damit kann man bestimmt auch gar nicht so wirklich was erreichen, weil ich denke mal, die Terroristen sind in der Hinsicht viel schlauer als diese Kameras, die das überwachen und ja.
Aber wir haben noch jetzt in London tatsächlich auch ein Fahndungserfolg gehabt.
Ja, schon, aber vielleicht war es dann auch nur Zufall oder so.
Wie ist es realistisch zu glauben, dass man sich von außen in irgendwelche Kameras dann auch einhakt und die Bilder abgreift zwischendurch?
Also du guckst jetzt mich an.
Ja, du bist hier doch der Lead Hacksore.
Wir wissen von einem Fall aus Österreich, wo tatsächlich über so eine WLAN, so eine Wireless LAN-Verbindung eine Kamera angebunden war.
Das weiß man aber auch nicht.
Doch, das ist tatsächlich gang und gäbe, aber normalerweise sind die Daten dann oder die Verbindung dann irgendwie schon gesichert, das heißt irgendwie verschlüsselt, war es da aber nicht. Und man konnte nicht nur die Kamerabilder angucken, sondern auch noch die Kamera fernsteuern. Das war also so eine Dome-Kamera oder so eine bewegliche Kamera. Eine Webcam. Und da konnte man dann auch fleißig mit rumzoomen. Nee, die war schon offiziell von der Polizei da angebracht. Nur leider hat man halt vergessen die Sicherheit zu aktivieren an dem System. Und je mehr Systeme es gibt in freier Wildbahn, desto größer ist auch die Anzahl von denen, die vielleicht vom Netz aus erreichbar sind oder von Unberechtigten auch benutzt werden können und missbraucht werden können vor allem auch. Klar, die Gefahr besteht auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich das Hauptproblem ist. Klar ist es auf jeden Fall ein Aspekt. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also du fühlst dich durch Kameras eher überwacht als beschützt. Aber was hast du denn zu verbergen?
Na, eigentlich so wirklich mein Privatleben zu verbergen. Ich will doch nicht, dass jeder weiß, was ich hier am Tag über mache.
Genau, das geht auch keinem was an.
Ich sag auch immer, irgendwann werden sie wissen wollen, was für Bücher du liest.
Das wissen sie doch, wenn man bei Amazon seine Bücher kauft. Stimmt.
Aber zum Beispiel hier bei uns im Schloss Neuharrenberg, da ist auch so eine Kamera und die beleuchtet da dieses eine Haus. Ja, und ich weiß nicht, also ich würde mich da voll beobachtet fühlen in ihrer Stelle, da wenn diese Kamera die ganze Zeit auf das Haus da leuchtet.
Also das ist ein Haus, in dem jemand wohnt?
Ja, also ich denke mal schon, da sind auch Gardinen und alles so vorher.
Es gibt aus Berlin zu dem Thema ein ganz interessantes Urteil, das ist das sogenannte Dussmann-Urteil, also Dussmann von dem Kulturkaufhaus in der Friedrichstraße. Die sind also per Gericht dazu verdonnert worden, dass sie ihre Kameras bitte auf ihr eigenes Haus richten möchten und nicht immer überall hin. Und sie dürfen jetzt, glaube ich, die Formulierung nur noch einen Meter um ihr Gebäude rum filmen, beobachten, das heißt, es geht darum, sie haben das begründet mit allem Möglichen und letztendlich sind sie, glaube ich, abgewichen in eine Bekämpfung von internationalem Terrorismus, da wurde es einem Richter dann auch ein bisschen zu bunt, was das dann mit einer privaten Gebäudeüberwachung zu tun hat. Und sie haben dann auch ganz stolz erzählt, dass sie auch irgendwie beim Juweliergegenüber auch irgendwie rein filmen konnten und damit auch schon einen Diebstahl aufgeklärt haben, so eine Sachen und das war aber halt alles ein bisschen zu offensichtlich, dreist. Und wir müssen sich ja darauf beschränken, den Bereich um einen Meter um ihr Gebäude auch dann zu filmen, zu überwachen.
Da gab es doch vor ein oder zwei Jahren in Köln auch diese Geschichte, wo auf der rechten Seite war das, irgendjemand mit einem Fahrrad einen Sprengsatz vor irgendeinem Laden abgestellt hat, der dann hochgegangen ist und der von der Kamera auf ein Viva-Gebäude, glaube ich, war das damals gefilmt wurde. Und da hat auch niemand gefragt, wie denn die Viva-Leute dazu kommen, einmal quer über die Straße irgendwie, da Köln zu filmen. Das ist dann untergegangen im Ermittlungsgeschehen.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn Sie wirklich hier Kameras in Deutschland und sich nicht wo aufstellen sollten, ja, dann würde ich es auch voll toll finden, wenn Kameras auch so, sag ich mal, jetzt in Berlin, das große Ding, wo der Bundeskanzler immer aufstellt. Reichstag, Reichstag. Genau, oh, Entschuldigung, dass da auch Kameras aufgestellt werden, weil letztens gab es doch einen Bericht hier, irgendwie 22 Toiletten waren voll mit Koks, ja, also oder Spuren halt so. Ja, und weiß nicht.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, möchtest du Guido Westerwelle oder Angela Merkel beim Pinkeln zusehen können?
Holger.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte euch jetzt nicht den Rest des Tages verderben.
Angela Merkel beim Koksen, wär interessant.
Nee, aber du hast recht, wir haben ein gleiches Recht für alle. Wir haben das vorhin auch schon diskutiert vor der Sendung, so ein bisschen der skandinavische Ansatz. Da ist halt die Idee, wir haben alle voreinander nichts zu verbergen. Und da ist halt wieder diese Balance zwischen Staat und Bürger. Da sind halt die, ich glaube, Norwegen ist das eins von den skandinavischen Staaten oben. Da sind auch die Steuererklärungen im Internet. Das heißt, da gibt es einen Namen ein von jemandem und bekommst dann deren Steuererklärung. Das heißt, was sie beim Finanzamt angegeben haben als Einkommen. Und da ist aber auch niemand gesperrt. Sie haben dann auch Sicherheit selber, dass die Leute nicht umständlich suchen müssen, denn auch ihre gesamte Chefredaktion, also das ist eine Zeitung, die diesen Service anbietet, die haben ihre gesamte Chefredaktion schon mal vorsorglich aufgelistet und die gesamte Regierung oder die Regierungsbeamte. Da ist dann halt diese Balance wieder ein bisschen andere als bei uns. Und das ist ja letztendlich das, was jetzt CCC schon seit der Volkszählung, seit der ersten fordert, ist, dass wir auch einen transparenten Staat, also sprich eine maschinenlesbare Regierung haben wollen. Und dass diese Balance einfach wieder, wobei das halt nicht heißt, dass wir dann unbedingt den Bundestagsabgeordneten beim Kuxen auf der Toilette zu gucken wollen.
Der Ralf schon.
Sondern dass wir einfach ein bisschen eher wissen wollen, was der Staat zu treiben ist. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, was wir haben, was zwar auch nur sehr eingeschränkt jetzt beschlossen worden ist, aber das ist zumindestens erstmal ein guter Schritt in die richtige Richtung, um diese Balance wieder herzustellen.
Aber das ist glaube ich schon noch ein Unterschied. Wenn ich Politiker wähle, dann will ich auch wissen, was die machen. Die handeln im öffentlichen Auftrag, genau wie die Behörden und die Leute, die da arbeiten. Was sie da dienstlich treiben, mit meinen Steuergeldern auf Grundlage von öffentlich erlassenden Gesetzen. Das will ich schon gerne kontrollieren können. Aber meine Steuererklärung im Internet, das fände ich schon ein bisschen heikel. Also das Land, Frank, was du da nanntest, das muss Norwegen sein, weil in der Europäischen Union wäre das nicht möglich. Spätestens seit der Datenschutzdirektive.
Das kann nur in Norwegen sein. Ich kann ja den Link auch nochmal raussuchen.
Haben wir Brandenburger runtergemacht?
Nur die Brandenburger Rechtsextremen. Aber das gilt natürlich auch für die Berliner Rechtsextremen. Die finden wir auch scheiße.
Wir finden alle Rechtsextremen scheiße.
Aber ich weiß nicht, also manche oder viele haben nur Erfnung. Also ich persönlich finde es nicht gerade gut hier, dass manche Ausländer hier in Brandenburg so wohnen einfach.
Dann bist du Rechtsextrem, dann finden wir dich auch scheiße. Dann bist du Rechtsextrem, wenn du dieser Meinung bist.
Na, aber guck dir mal, viele Leute haben überhaupt keine Arbeit hier und so. Die Ausländer, sag ich mal, kriegen jetzt die Arbeit einfach hingeschmissen und gehen halt nicht.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht. Wie viele Ausländer kennst du, die einen deutschen Arbeit weggenommen haben? Oder andersrum gefragt, wie viele Deutsche kennst du, die die Drecksarbeit machen würden, die die Ausländer machen? Tut mir leid Susi, aber du bist komplett, was das angeht, bist du nicht wirklich gut informiert. Ich empfehle dir dringend mal Zeitung zu lesen oder sowas zu machen und nicht nachzuplappern, was du irgendwo auf der Straße aufschnappst. Weil das wär's nicht wert. Ja, schade, ne? Kommen wir mal zu Sebastian. Sebastian?
Ja, Gruß.
Du bist Ausländer, ne?
Ja, ja, ich bin Ausländer, genau.
Wie finden denn die Briten das, wenn so Ausländer in Großbritannien rumhängen, so wie du?
Also ich bin grad wütend geworden. Ich wollte Susi grad noch hinterher schicken, dass es in London mit Sicherheit genauso viele ausländische Arbeitgeber wie Arbeitnehmer gibt und dass das nur dadurch funktioniert und total klasse ist.
Ja, in Deutschland sieht es ja genauso aus, nur das wollen die Rechtsradikalen alle nicht begreifen, weil die ja nicht lesen können. Schade. Wie lebt es sich mit permanenter Kameraüberwachung?
Ja, das ist was, was mir am Anfang aufgefallen ist, aber inzwischen schon irgendwie, ich sag mal so im alltäglichen Leben merkt man es nicht mehr wirklich. Aber ich bin, sag ich mal prinzipiell auf jeden Fall dem auch sehr kritisch gegenüber eingestellt. Und darauf wollte ich jetzt auch hinaus. Und zwar ist dieses Argument mit dem, was hast du denn zu verbergen, auf der einen Seite klar das erste Argument, was einem kommt, um das gut zu heißen. Auf der anderen Seite kommt es natürlich immer auf den, an der dahinter sitzt hinter der Kamera, was der denn meint, was man verbergen muss sozusagen und was nicht. Und am Endeffekt, das Fazit auch für die ganzen Anrufer, finde ich es so, dass Überwachung eine unglaubliche Macht ist, bei der es extrem gefährlich ist, an wen die geht. Ich meine, solange jemand dahinter sitzt, der die gleichen Aufpassungen wie man selbst hat, quasi sicher, aber sobald das abweicht, ist natürlich ein Problem da.
Weißt du denn zufälligerweise, wer das in London macht, also wo die Daten auflaufen? Also wer in diesen Videozentralen sitzt und sich die Bilder anguckt?
Ich denke, vieles davon ist auf jeden Fall relativ privat. Also auf jeden Fall der Underground und im Bankerviertel ist ja alles voll und es wird bestimmt sehr viel privat sein und der Rest habe ich keine Ahnung.
Also warte mal, Eric. In Großbritannien insgesamt ist praktisch die Überwachung der Straßen und Plätzen eher in der Hand der kommunalen Behörden. Also das sind im größten Teil Angestellte der Stadt. Aber es gibt halt zudem, muss man sagen, in London ist eine Planung und läuft zum Teil halt schon, dass eben genau die Kameras dieser kommunalen Behörden zur Polizei aufgeschaltet werden. Also selbst 2006 soll es in London ein sogenanntes C3I-Zentrum der Polizei wo ungefähr 3000 Kameras auflaufen, die natürlich nicht alle in Echtzeit beobachtet werden. Aber sie können eben, die Polizei kann flexibel, je nach Anlass dann sich danach anschalten.
Wusste ich nicht, aber auf jeden Fall interessant.
3000? Das ist ein interessanter Aspekt, finde ich. Man fängt im privaten Bereich an, irgendwelche Supermärkte bauen sich Kameras ein oder private Betreiber irgendwo. Und wenn die Infrastruktur erstmal da ist, dann ist natürlich bei der Polizei auch sehr schnell der Bedarf da, auf die Daten auch zugreifen zu können. Das haben wir aber bei Internetdaten genauso im Moment.
Das ist genau was, was wenn es Überwachung gibt, denke ich zumindest, dass absolut abgesichert sein muss, an wen diese Daten gehen dürfen und an wen nicht. Und das ist ein Ding, was natürlich absolut leuchtrig ist, was bei einem riesen technischen Aufwand und diesem Wahnsinn, wenn das überall installiert ist, im Endeffekt gar nicht mehr nachprüfbar ist, denke ich.
Wie ist denn die Stimmung in London? Also hier bei uns heißt es jetzt wieder, ja, da seht ihr mal, wenn wir nur in Deutschland flächendeckend Video überwachen würden, dann wären wir immerhin in der Lage, für den Fall, dass irgendwann mal ein solcher Anschlag passiert, hinterher besser aufklären zu können, nimmt der Londoner das wahr?
Na ja, wenn sich jemand selbst in die Luft sprengt, dann bringt die Nase auf dem Bild danach wenig. Also das hat in diesem Falle bei den Zieren, die sich selbst in die Luft gesprengt haben, auch nicht gebracht. Und die vier anderen, gut, dass einer gefasst worden wäre, früher oder später wahrscheinlich sowieso. Also es ist nun eine Sache der Aufklärung danach. Und wenn derjenige sich selbst in die Luft gesprengt hat, kann man natürlich höchstens versuchen, darüber dann die Identität schneller festzustellen, als es ohnehin der Fall wäre. Aber ich glaube, wirklich einen Unterschied machen tut es nicht.
Ich sehe ja gerade so ein Bild, was glaube ich jemand mit seinem Kamerahandy fotografiert hat von der Londoner U-Bahn. Das ist eine Service Information an alle Passagiere, dass man auf den Bahnsteigen bitte nicht rennen möchte. Und ganz besonders nicht, wenn man einen Rucksack dabei hat. Oder eine große, was ist das, Coat zu lesen?
Einen Mantel, ja.
Was wäre Mantel oder ein Rucksack dabei? Es sollte nicht rennen, sonst wird er niedergestreckt.
Oder wenn man ein bisschen foreign, also ausländisch aussieht. Dann auch nicht.
Das ist zu ihrer eigenen Sicherheit.
Genau.
Die Stimmung ist momentan auf jeden Fall angespannt als nach den ersten Anschlägen, finde ich. Weil die ersten Anschläge haben die Brit wirklich darauf gewartet. Wir haben seit vier Jahren, seit 9-11, wirklich mehr oder weniger, sind viele davon ausgegangen, dass es irgendwann passieren muss. Dann kam es einmal und genauso wie in Amerika, dachte niemand, dass es gleich wieder passiert.
Das ist so wie beim neuen Auto. Die erste Beule tut noch weh und danach ist egal.
Nee, eher umgedreht. Der erste Anschlag war, sag ich mal, schlimm. Und danach haben die Leute sich aber gesagt, gut, let's go on the ride.
Und als nächstes sind die Australier dran, oder die Polen, oder wenn noch im Irak im Einsatz waren.
Das will Berlusconi gerne, um sich wichtig zu machen. Als nächstes sind bestimmt wir dran. Ganz bestimmt sind wir dran.
Das Bild ist ja bekloppt.
Ich glaube, das sagt man gerade überall in der Welt.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Auf jeden Fall wollte ich auch auf was anderes hinaus. Die Überwachung finde ich sehr interessant, wenn sich das privat und öffentlich vermischt. Insofern, zum Beispiel Malls, das ist ein ziemlich interessantes Beispiel. Also Einkaufsmalls. Wenn man in einen privaten Laden geht, da wird privat überwacht und wenn man in so einen kleinen Laden geht, weiß man worauf man sich einlässt, man wird dort aufgezeichnet. Wenn man in einem bestimmten öffentlichen Raum ist, auf der Straße, weiß man es auch. Nun ist eine Mall ja zwar ein Laden, aber auf der anderen Seite wirkt, also so eine große Mall, die hat, sag ich mal, kleine Straßen, wo man durchläuft, das ist überdacht, da ist künstliches Licht drin. Aber das wird im Endeffekt so angelegt, wie ein kleines Stadtzentrum, wo verschiedene Läden und Cafés und so weiter drin sind. Und das Ganze ist privat überwacht. Und das finde ich was sehr Schwieriges, zum Beispiel, weil diese Mall zwar privat ist, aber mit ihrer Architektur und mit allem Drum und Dran suggeriert, in öffentlicher Platz zu sein. Und in vielen Städten ja sogar in Kleinstädten das Zentrum von früher, sag ich mal, übernimmt und auch die Funktion übernimmt, dass dort sich bestimmte Leute treffen.
Das sind der sogenannte öffentlich zugängliche Raum quasi. Das ist auch ein ganz großes Problem, auch was das Hausrecht angeht, in so einem Einkaufszentrum.
Ja genau. Und da finde ich zum Beispiel wird es sehr schwierig, wie das weitergeht, wenn Malls oder private, ja, sag ich mal, was auch immer läden oder private Einrichtungen immer mehr öffentliches Leben übernehmen, wo Leute sich treffen und so weiter und so fort, wo man gar nicht drum rumkommt. Und da gibt es zu dem Thema einen sehr interessanten Bericht in der Guardian, den ich vor kurzem gelesen habe. Nicht direkt zur Überwachung, aber da hat eine Mall eine Survey gemacht, also eine, wie sagt man, Untersuchung, wie viele oder was für Kunden, sag ich mal, ankommen und welche Kunden eher abschrecken und so weiter. Und so wie das Bild sozusagen in der Mall ist, es war bei, den Namen hab ich vergessen, von der Mall, von der Kette. Auf jeden Fall ist dabei rausgekommen, dass die ganzen Kids, die 16-jährigen, in die Schule zu gehen, da rumhängen. Und alle, sag ich mal, so eigen geordnet werden können, die erkennen wir daran, dass sie Nike-Torn-Schuhe und Base-Caps aufhaben. Und da wurde jetzt ernsthaft in dieser ganzen Kette, die es in englischen Kleinstädten mindestens fünfmal gibt, wurde so eine hausinterne Ordnung erlassen, dass Base-Caps in der Mall nicht mehr erlaubt sind. Und seitdem werden dort kategorisch alle, die mit Base-Caps reinkommen, gefragt, die absetzen oder rausgeschmissen.
Hast du dann einen Link zu oder kannst du diesen Artikel vielleicht finden?
Ich wünschte, ich hätte ihn aufgehoben. Das war schon eine Weile her, das war in der Guardian, vor vielleicht drei Monaten. Also man könnte höchstens online recherchieren, vielleicht, um das rausfinden. Und das finde ich eine sehr interessante Sache, weil da hat irgendjemand eine Untersuchung gemacht, festgestellt, die Kunden stören andere Kunden, die sehen so und so aus. Und das geht jetzt sogar in Fashion rein. Was hat ein Base-Cap bitteschön mit Gesinnung oder was auch immer zu tun? Und die Leute werden es herausgeschmissen. Oder eben sollen sie absetzen. Und das ist da, wo es gefährlich wird. Die Mauer suggeriert, in öffentlicher Platz zu sein, hat aber ihre eigenen Gesetze.
Das wäre aber was für einen CCC, kostenlos Base-Caps verteilen. Vor allem eingehen.
Genau, das habe ich überlegt. Man müsste echt vor den Eingang stellen und kostenlos Base-Caps an alle, die reingehen, verteilen.
Vielen Dank Sebastian.
Alles klar.
Und eine gute Nacht. Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand ist unser Thema heute Abend hier in der Sendung. Du guckst so, als wolltest du irgendwas Schlaues sagen gerade.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Eric wollte was Schlaues sagen.
Nochmal eine Ergänzung zu dem Vorredner. Also zum einen die Vermischung von öffentlich und privat. Das ist denke ich eines der größten Probleme, was wir hierzulande immer stärker haben. Also wir haben halt in Großbritannien die Vermischung zwischen Polizei und kommunalen Behörden, aber eben auch immer Mehrheit zwischen Privaten und Polizei. Und es ist auch hierzulande so, dass eben zum Beispiel es gibt eine Richtlinie polizeientern für die Aufschaltung von stillen Alarmanlagen zur Polizei, zu der lokalen Wache. Also es ist durchaus so, dass es Banken und Museen gibt, wo die Polizei schon Zugriff auf die Innenraumkameras hat. Wenn der Beibesitzer damit einverstanden ist, sogar mit Fernbedienung. Also es ist auch hier nicht mehr so weit weg. Ich meine, nutzen sie es natürlich wahrscheinlich nur, wenn da irgendwie ein stiller Alarm geschaltet wird. Aber wenn sie diese Fernbedienungsoption haben, kann man sich vorstellen, was da alles möglich ist.
Das heißt, es weckt auf jeden Fall immer Begehrlichkeit. Warum leckt er und sich die Eier?
Und zum anderen hat die massive Überwachung durch private Sicherheitsdienste natürlich auch Begehrlichkeit. Es gab mal einen etwas exklusiveren Kreis. Es war eine Tagung von privaten Sicherheitsdiensten. Da dachte der damalige sächsische Innenminister Klaus Hardrad darüber nach, dass man die Überwachung der Privaten wunderbar nutzen könnte, um die verfassungsrechtlichen Grenzen der polizeilichen oder für die polizeiliche Überwachung zu umgehen.
Was ähnliches gibt es gerade in den USA seit einer Weile, wo relativ strenge Datenschutzgesetze für Bundesbehörden bestehen. Seit 1974 gibt es einen Privacy Act, der aber eben nur für den Regierungsbereich gilt, was die an Daten erfassen dürfen und nutzen und weitergeben und so weiter. Für den privaten Bereich gibt es bis auf wenige Ausnahmen wie Finanzsektor oder sowas überhaupt keine Datenschutzregelung, also keine Gesetze oder sowas wie in Deutschland. Und das Department for Homeland Security ist jetzt seit einer Weile dabei, am überlegen, wie kann man, oder machen es teilweise auch schon, wie kann man sozusagen die ganzen Daten, die von privaten Firmen gespeichert werden, von Amazon, von was weiß ich wem alles, Einkaufskundendaten und so, wie kann man die nutzen, um sozusagen die, alles was der Staat nicht darf, weil es ihm per Gesetz verboten ist, durch Verfassung oder sowas, dass das sozusagen in dem privaten Bereich ausgelagert wird. Also sozusagen Vorfeldorganisationen der Sicherheits- und Geheimdienste da im privaten Bereich zu installieren. Und das ist natürlich sehr heikel, weil man da eigentlich sozusagen die grundrechtlichen verfassungsrechtlichen Beschränkungen von staatlichem Handeln umgehen will.
Ich retz es an, Jürgen Blumun, das Chaosradio 104, Chaosradio gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat und heute ist unser Thema, Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand. Frank im Studio, der Erik im Studio von der TU Berlin und der Ralf von der Dingens von der Uni in Bremen, da gibt es nur eine.
Ja. Na es gibt noch eine International University.
International University, das klingt aber halbseitend dubios.
Wir wollen heute ein bisschen reden über die ganzen Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die jetzt gefordert werden nach den Anschlägen von London. Wir wollen mal schauen, was hier in Deutschland auch erwartet wird oder gefordert wird von der Bundestagswahl. Die steht ja wohl vor der Tür, so wie es aussieht. Auch da werden von der konservativen Seite vor allem viele Versprechungen gemacht, was uns mehr Kameras, mehr Überwachung, mehr Datenspeicherung an Sicherheit bringen soll. Und heute Abend reden wir einfach mal ein bisschen darüber, was es denn tatsächlich bringt und vor allem, was ihr glaubt euch das bringt. Bringt es mehr Sicherheit, fühlt ihr euch überwacht. Ist es alles gut, was da passiert, ist es vor allem gut für die Demokratie oder kann unsere Demokratie viel besser und mit weniger Überwachung leben?
0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritz-Hotline. Ihr seid natürlich eingeladen anzurufen und mitzudiskutieren.
Ja, wir haben eben schon das Thema angesprochen, der kategorischen Überwachung. Also Leute werden eben nicht immer nach ihrem Verhalten beurteilt, ob sie sich verdächtig verhalten oder einen Straftat begehen, sondern das inzwischen halt häufig dazu übergegangen wird, Leute nach ihrem Aussehen zu beurteilen, eben zu gucken, was für Kleidung sie anhaben, welche Hautfarbe sie haben, ob sie Kopftücher tragen oder nicht. Und das bestätigt sich für Videoüberwachung offensichtlich auch. In Großbritannien hat es Studien gegeben, wo sowohl in den Malls als auch im öffentlichen Zugang, also als auch auf Straßen und Plätzen halt insbesondere Farbige überwacht werden. Ob das dann für die Konsequenzen hat, ist jetzt noch eine andere Frage, aber zumindest werden sie bevorzugt halt überwacht. In Frankreich lässt sich ähnliches zeigen, da geht es hauptsächlich gegen die Jugend aus den Vorstädten.
Na ja, wenn es zu gar nichts führt, führt es immerhin noch dazu, dass im Radio, wie zum Beispiel jetzt drüber geredet wird, und es auf einmal wieder irgendwelche Leute gibt, die das in den falschen Hals kriegen, denken, wenn die ja bevorzugt überwacht werden, dann müssen sie ja auch was am... Wenn der Neger nicht böse wäre, dann würde er ja nicht gefilmt. Das ist ja was in den Köpfen der dummen Menschen vorgeht.
Na klar, und letztlich ist es natürlich auch eine sich selbst verfüllende Prophezeiung. Wenn man hauptsächlich Leute beobachtet, dann ist klar, dann nimmt man die Straftaten von der bestimmten Bevölkerungsgruppe eher zu Kenntnis als die von anderen und sowohl in deren Vorurteile verstärkt.
Aber das hat, glaube ich, noch einen viel weitergehenden Aspekt. Es ist vielleicht im Moment noch so, dass auf bestimmte Leute vielleicht eher mal geguckt wird bei solchen Kameras oder bei ähnlichen Überwachungsmaßnahmen, aber wenn die sozusagen nichts anstellen, dann passiert ihnen auch nichts. Was man aber mit diesen ganzen Sachen, ob es Kameras sind oder Internetüberwachung oder was weiß ich, installiert und nach und nach immer stärker ausbaut, ist ja eine Infrastruktur von Überwachung. Und wo man glaube ich da aufpassen muss ist, falls es mal irgendwann durch blöde Umstände hier einen politischen Systemwechsel geben sollte, dann ist diese ganze Technologie einfach schon mal da, die ganze Infrastruktur und dann kann damit richtig viel Scheiße passieren. Es gibt da ein schönes Beispiel aus den 30er Jahren, also was heißt schön eigentlich? Ein furchtbares Beispiel, aber was das glaube ich ganz anschaulich macht, die Niederlande hatten in den 30er Jahren sehr umfangreiche Bevölkerungsregister schon angelegt, wo unter anderem auch die Religionszugehörigkeit erfasst wurde. War alles kein Problem, Niederland war ein demokratisches Land und so, den Leuten passierte auch sozusagen nichts, bloß weil sie als Katholiken oder Juden oder Atheisten eingetragen waren. Nur dann sind plötzlich die Deutschen da einmarschiert, haben innerhalb von drei Tagen sofort nach der Besetzung Hollands sämtliche Bevölkerungsregister sichergestellt, mit dem Ergebnis, dass von den holländischen Juden pro Kopf mehr gestorben sind, als sogar von den Deutschen. Also einfach dadurch, dass diese Infrastruktur schon da war und die Leute alle erfasst waren und sozusagen die, damals noch auf Papier, aber sozusagen diese Datenbanken da waren, konnten sie dann unter anderen Umständen einfach auch sehr furchtbar genutzt werden. Und das sollte man glaube ich immer im Kopf behalten.
Jetzt wird hier aber jeder an den Kopf werfen, dass so was nicht mehr passieren kann, weil wir gegen einen solchen Systemwechsel doch gefeit sein müssen.
Man kann ein ähnliches Beispiel natürlich nicht mit dem Folgen einer Massenvernichtung bringen, aber in den Vereinigten Staaten aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg so, dass halt auch die Volkszählungsstaaten, die eigentlich auch anonymisiert gehandhabt werden sollten, dann nach dem Angriff der Japaner auf Paul Harber gegen die japanischstämmige Bevölkerung genutzt wurde, die dann massiv kassaniert wurde.
Also selbst eine stabile Demokratie, was die USA zu dem Zeitpunkt auf jeden Fall waren, nicht dagegen gefeit.
Ja und gerade in Zeiten von Sicherheitswahn ist ja das Thema eine Wendung hier und Terrorangst und sowas, gibt es glaube ich auch so was wie eine schleichende Auflösung von Demokratie, die nicht unbedingt durch eine Wahl von einem neuen Hitler oder sowas für alle offensichtlich stattfindet, sondern so nach und nach so ganz bisschen unter der Haut und Schritt für Schritt sozusagen sich so reinschleicht.
Passiert das schon?
Wir haben eine gefährliche Tendenz in die Richtung.
Aufgabentrennung, Aufhebung der Aufgabentrennung zwischen polizei- und Geheimdiensten.
Also wo ich im Moment noch drauf vertraue sind unsere Verfassungsrichter hier. Die haben ja gerade jetzt in Niedersachsen einfach da auch mal ein paar Sachen abgeschmettert. Die Frage ist, wie lange die sich halten können. Und wenn jetzt unter der nächsten Regierung vielleicht auch mehr konservative Verfassungsrichter installiert werden und so. Schauen wir mal.
Gibt es denn wirklich Grund zur Sorge, also jetzt aus eurem universitären Betrieb heraus, also ihr seid politisch...
Nein, das muss nicht zum Völkermord gehen. Aber das kann einfach heißen, dass Leuten Berufschancen kaputt gemacht werden. Es gibt zum Beispiel in den USA extreme Schwierigkeiten seit dem 11.9. für ausländische Wissenschaftler oder so. Also da, wo ich so ein bisschen Leute auch kenne, Jobs zu kriegen oder einfach nur für wissenschaftliche Tagungen in die USA einzureisen.
0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer. Der Fritz Hotline ist nach wie vor eingeladen, mit uns zu diskutieren bzw. eure Meinung oder eure Haltung zur Frage von Sicherheitswahn, der uns ja gerade heim sucht, insbesondere aus konservativen Kreisen, wenn wir uns so die Politik angucken bzw. gucken, was Fräulein Christiansen so für Leute zu Wort kommen lässt jeden Sonntagabend. 0331 77 97 110 hat der Kirill angerufen aus Berlin-Lichtenberg.
Ja, hallo. Also erstmal wollte ich ganz gerne sagen, dass ihr verdammt doll meinen Gutrahmen belastet. Weil ich schon seit 15 Minuten über dem Handy drinnen hängen. Aber meine Meinung, Kirill Kunz zu tun, war mir so wichtig, dass ich jetzt mal spontan sage, was ich gemacht habe. Ja, also was ich erstmal sagen wollte, ich denke mal Videoüberwachung keilt keinen Terroristen ab. Das ist nunmal so.
Und jetzt auch gerade, also ich meine, wenn es ein Selbstmordattentäter ist, dann ist es dem doch auch egal.
Jaja, genau, dann ist es dem egal. Und deswegen bringt das nichts. Wenn es natürlich kein Selbstmordattentäter ist, ist klar, dann ist es leichter zu verfolgen, wie das auch in London geschehen ist. Da weiß man ja schon, die bei dem letzten, glaube ich, Terroranschlag oder der versuchte dort, also die wurden ja schon fachkundig gemacht und so. Also ich denke halt, da bringt das nicht allzu viel. Aber ich denke, gerade in Sicherheit belangen jetzt die sowieso Kriminalität, die es auch hier in Berlin gibt, was man wirklich niemals verschweigen kann, denke ich, dass das eine Menge hilft, wenn die öffentlichen Plätze überwacht sind. Weil dann wird sich vielleicht der Typ zweimal überlegen, ob er jemand zusammenschlägt oder ob er jemand das Geld klauen will oder so. Und wenn er das dann macht, dann sieht man das auch deutlich.
Ein schönes Beispiel vielleicht auch da oder Gegenbeispiel da. Am Hermannplatz in Berlin, da kannst du super Drogen kaufen und in der U-Bahn. Und irgendwann ist mal der Bezirk oder Senat oder wer auch immer hingegangen hat gesagt, so wir verhindern das jetzt und haben da massiv kontrolliert und die ganze Zeit Druck ausgeübt auf die Drogenhändler und Konsumenten, die da am Hermannplatz sich das Zeug gekauft haben. Und die sind einfach eine Station ausgewichen Richtung in die Bordinenstraße.
Da hab ich gewohnt zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Dann müsste es ja eine relative Flächenüberwachung sein. Aber ich meine, ich bin auch ein Typ, ich geh auch abends in Diskurs. Ich bin da manchmal auch besoffen und laufe irgendwie sinkt durch die Straßen. Da würde ich mich auch durch Kameras nicht beeinflusst fühlen oder so in meinem Verhalten. Ich meine, ich weiß, wenn ich irgendwas mache, dann mach ich ja nichts Kriminelles und dann finde ich das wäre okay.
Aber wenn dann irgendwie zum dritten Mal jemand kommt und meint, dich maßregeln zu müssen, weil du singend durch die Gegend läufst, wirst du dann nicht vielleicht auch beim vierten Mal lassen?
Na ja, wenn das verboten ist, dann mach ich das nicht. Warum soll ich das machen? Aber ich sehe das jetzt nicht als mehr. Dann gibt es eben Ruhestörungen, aber das ist dann halt nur ein Delikt. Und deswegen finde ich das jetzt nicht allzu schlimm. Und ich muss auch sagen, wirklich, es gab schon so oft Situationen, in denen man sich sowas oder in solchen Situationen hätte ich mir das gewünscht. In solchen Situationen hätten sich das auch Bekannte gewünscht, dass es Videoüberwachung gibt. Aber was ich dann auch sage, es sollte auf jeden Fall in staatlicher Sache bleiben. Also ich finde, Gesundheit und Sicherheit, das sind Sachen, das sind wesentliche Staatsthemen. Also die sollten nicht irgendwie in privater Hand über private Sicherheitsdienste beschäftigt werden. Nämlich zum Beispiel ein gutes Beispiel in Russland oder beziehungsweise Moskau. Ich war erst letztens dort oder auch in Polen, das ist so. Dort gibt es einen Haufen private Sicherheitsdienste und die regeln dort einzelne Geschäfte. Und die privaten Sicherheitsdienste sind dort auch quasi die, also die sind eigentlich im Prinzip mehr, naja, wert. Also sind halt wichtiger als die Polizei und sowas finde ich dann negativ. Und ich denke aber, wir haben so ein System und da muss das einfach die Polizei übernehmen.
Aber diese Situation, wo du dir Kameras gewünscht hättest, was war das zum Beispiel?
Na ja, zum Beispiel, da kommen dann halt ein paar, jetzt eine Fünfer Gruppe oder so an, mit Messern, wollen Geld haben und so. Und okay, das ist dann letztendlich ganz glimpslich abgelaufen, weil nichts passiert ist. Aber das ist halt allgegenwärtig in Berlin und man hört es ja immer wieder. Und deswegen wäre es in Berlin auf jeden Fall voll, die sind volle Maßnahmen.
Also allgegenwärtig ist aber ein bisschen übertrieben, oder?
Ja, das ist noch nie passiert. Mir ist es noch nie passiert. Ich lebe seit 12 Jahren in Berlin.
Ja, okay, aber ich meine, die Kriminalität gerade und gerade auch unter Jugendlichen sprechen für sich. Also ich denke, da muss ich jetzt keinen, ja, also...
Ja, aber glaubst du denn, dass man genau das, zum Beispiel in der Schule, was passiert im Klassenraum, sonst irgendwo, dass man das durch Kameras irgendwie verhindern könnte?
Ich spreche jetzt nicht von Schule, Klassenraum, sondern von Schulhof oder der Kaufhalle davor oder halt auch nachts und da ist das wichtig, denke ich.
Ja, aber glaubst du wirklich, dass die Kamera das verhindert?
Also naja, okay, wenn es es erstmal nicht verhindert, dann ist der Typ, der das gemacht hat, auf jeden Fall schon mal mit einem Bein beim Jugendrichter. So viel steht schon mal fest.
Ich glaube, du überschätzt da ein bisschen auch die Möglichkeiten der Videoüberwachung.
Ja, wir haben doch schon gehört. Ich meine, von den Anrufen hier wurde das als die große Überwachung hier gegeißelt und gesagt, das ist ja total Schock für unser System. Und ich meine, da überschätze ich die Möglichkeiten jetzt, glaube ich, nicht.
Naja, also der Täter muss halt wirklich schon auch genau, mehr oder weniger genau vor der Kamera stehen. So und das heißt natürlich, dass wenn du mit einer Kamera, sage ich mal, einen Bereich von 5x5, 10x10 Meter filmst, so dann ist tatsächlich da noch was zu erkennen. Jetzt kannst du mir ausrechnen, wenn du Berlin überwachen willst, wie viele Millionen Kameras du da installieren musst.
Ja ok, das ist natürlich ein berechtigter Einwand, aber vielleicht könnte man dort auch auf den Abschreckungseffekt setzen in diesem Fall. Oder man macht halt...
Aber genau dann muss der eben die Millionen von Kameras in Berlin installieren, weil sonst passiert der Überfall halt ein paar Meter weiter, wo die Kamera dann nicht mehr ist.
Ich hab zum Thema Abschreckung, habe ich auch noch immer so ein schönes Totschlagargument. In den USA gibt es die Todesstrafe. Und das soll eigentlich Leute abschrecken, Verbrechen zu begehen, auf die die Todesstrafe steht. Und genau das Gegenteil passiert eigentlich. Also sie begehen einfach diese Verbrechen, ohne sich darum zu scheren, ob es Todesstrafe gibt oder nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde den Begriff der Abschreckung immer sehr, sehr heikel. Also ich glaube, dass jemand, der etwas tun will, sich durch nichts davon abhalten lässt. Es sei denn, du sperrst ihn weg von Anfang an.
Nein, es gibt doch ein Sprichwort, das heißt Gelegenheit macht Diebe. Und ich denke, so ist es auch.
Okay, Punkt für dich. Ja stimmt.
Ja, also das ist halt mein Argument dort. Insofern, ja, okay, Todesstrafe ist natürlich klar.
Schönes Todesstrafe.
Richtig, aber ja, genau. Und was ich vorhin noch sagen wollte, ich habe da dann noch am Ende die Bemerkung zu Susi mitzukommen. Also erst mal, um das klarzustellen, ich bin Russe, ich bin selber Ausländer, ich habe einen russischen Pass. Und insofern lasse ich mich da jetzt nicht als rechts oder so geißen. Aber es ist in Fakt so, dass manche Ausländer, jetzt speziell Polen, den Deutschen oder einigen Deutschen die Arbeitswitze wegnehmen.
Ja, aber das Argument, Kirill, stopp mal.
Das Argument, das Argument. Na, es gibt so viele Arbeitslose hier in Deutschland und den Ausländern, die kommen hier hin und die kriegen die Arbeit dann hingeschmissen. Das ist ein Argument, das lasse ich nicht gelten. Das ist dummes Zeug, das irgendwo aufgegriffen und nachplappert.
Das habe ich auch nicht gehört.
Das hat Susi aber gesagt vorhin.
Ja, okay, dann tut es mir leid, das habe ich nicht so ganz wahrgenommen. Ich wollte jetzt als Beispiel noch anzügen. Es ist ja zum Beispiel so, dass es in Polen diverse Firmen gibt, die sich dann auf einmal aus dem Nichts gründen, dass sie hier arbeiten können.
Arbeitnehmerüberlassungskriminalität ist auf jeden Fall vorhanden. Aber ich denke nicht, dass das ein Argument für Rassismus in jedweder Form sein darf.
Das hat auch nichts mit Rassismus zu tun.
Das ist Wirtschaftskriminalität.
Ich sage bloß, dass das relativ oft passiert und dass man das deswegen nicht totschweigen sollte. Ich betrachte mich selber als Links, aber ich finde, sowas muss man auch als Liker sagen dürfen.
Natürlich, solange es vor allen Dingen... Wie gesagt, ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit, wenn irgendjemand irgendetwas behauptet, was er belegen kann. Aber die nehmen uns allen die Arbeitsplätze weg. Es ist ein dumpfes Gelaber, das kann Holger Apfel machen, wenn er... von mir ist ein lieben langer Tag. Aber bitte niemand, der seinen Kopf zum Denken benutzt.
Um nochmal auf dieses Video überwachen zu können, ich denke, naja, natürlich, das ist natürlich eine ganz schöne Leistung. Wenn ich mir jetzt vorstellen würde, ich gucke hier gerade auf den Fernsehturm und auf die Skyline von Berlin, dass das hier alles mit Kameras eingedeckt werden sollte, wäre das natürlich eine ganz schöne technische Leistung. Vielleicht ist das auch zu teuer, aber jedenfalls denke ich, dass das jetzt erstmal nicht so das Schlimme ist, was passieren kann. Also ich halte das eher positiv.
Guck mal nach Leipzig, da wartet auch schon lang der Martin. Hallo Martin.
Ich wollte mal loswerden, mein mehr oder weniger großes Angenerve von den vielen Kameras und speziell bei Banken. Also wenn ich irgendwo Geld abheben gehe. Also Beispiel hier, Spaßkasse bei uns um die Ecke, komme ich rein, sehe eine Kamera, gucke nach links, sehe die zweite, drehe mich rum, sehe die dritte und schaue nach rechts und sehe die vierte.
Und gucken die auch auf das Ding, wo du deine Geheimnummer eintippen musst?
Du hast aber die fünfte Kamera noch nicht entdeckt, die nehme ich genau im Geldautomaten.
Die fünfte habe ich jetzt auch entdeckt, die ist nämlich hinter der Säule.
Also wenn man von Automaten steht, genau über meinem Kopf.
Das ist noch eine im Automaten.
Die guckt dich genau an.
Achso, ja, ja. Na der wink ich immer fröhlich. Und den anderen, die schaue ich immer nur böse an. Aber die eine, die genau über meinem Kopf ist, die schaut meines 18 nach auch genau aufs Nummernfeld. Und da bin ich zur Bankangestellten gegangen. Hab gesagt hier, schön guten Tag, die Kamera schaut genau aufs Bedienfeld. Und da hat die wie selbstverständlich, als wäre ich nicht der erste, gesagt, nein dem ist nicht so, das muss so sein, das ist okay.
Hättest du mal sagen sollen, darf ich dann mal bitte das Bild sehen, den Bildausschnitt? Also müssen die einem jetzt zeigen?
Nee, ne?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich frage hier gerade in die Runde, also du hast natürlich schon ein juristisches Auskunftsrecht und wenn da sozusagen der dringende Verdacht besteht?
Echt?
Also letztendlich.
Pah, dann werde ich nächste Woche im Media Markt mal richtig auf die Kacke hauen gehen.
Also das ist zumindest ein interessanter Fall, wenn die Kamera wirklich auf dieses Hinterzeichen.
Ich denke schon, ich habe mein Kopf aufs Bedienfeld gelegt und nach oben geschaut und schaue genau in die Linse.
Man kann glaube ich nicht direkt sagen, hier ich will jetzt das Bild sehen. Man kann aber auf jeden Fall zum Landesschutzbeauftragten gehen und sich bei dem über den Media Markt oder die Sparkasse beschweren. Und der muss der Sache danach gehen. Der sitzt hier in Berlin am...
Leipzig.
Ach so, Leipzig. Ja, die sind, weiß ich nicht, aber... Gibt es auch im Westen. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Datenschutzpunkt, was ist denn das? Datenschutzpunkt Sachsenpunkt.de, würde ich sagen. Da findest du sie.
Ja, irgend sowas, genau.
Ich glaub sogar unter Datenschutz.de hast du ja noch ein bisschen von einem.
Das zweite Ding, was ich hab, auch wieder eine Spaßkasse, diesmal in Chemnitz. Da war es so, die war immer mal heimgesucht worden, abends, meistens in der Nacht, von irgendwelchen Betrunknen, die da ihr Geschäft verrichtet haben. Ach, die war auch videobewacht. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass nach ungefähr zwei Wochen, wo das dann halt häufiger vorkam, die Spaßkasse abends zugemacht hat. Und da stand ein Zettel draußen dran, wir machen nicht mehr auf wegen der Verunreinigung. Und da sehe ich dann halt auch nicht ein, warum da eine Kamera ist. Und ja, schön, wo ist das, wenn die offensichtlich dann keiner überwacht, die Kamera oder nutzt, oder... Da hat sich eigentlich überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Was nutzt das am nächsten Tag, wenn der Typ einen Basecap anhatte, ne? Vielen Dank, Martin. Und www.datenschutz.de ist wirklich die Adresse, die du ansurfen möchtest. Tschüss.
Ich würde gerne noch kurz von Eric aus seinem Forschungsprojekt. Ich habe das ja immerhin ein paar Jahre lang untersucht, auch mit Kollegen im europäischen Ausland. Mal was hören zur Effektivität von dieser Überwachung. Wirkt das wirklich abschreckend? Verhindert das Straftaten? Welche Art von Straftaten?
Also fangen wir vielleicht noch früher an. Was genau habt ihr untersucht und wann und wo?
Also wir haben drei Jahre lang relativ verschiedene, also sehr unterschiedliche Sachen untersucht. Zwar Thema Videoüberwachung, aber es ging halt um rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen in den unterschiedlichen Ländern. Wie ist die öffentliche Debatte? Also man kann zum Beispiel sagen, in Deutschland wird sehr kritisch diskutiert. In England kräht eigentlich kein Hahn mehr danach. Und auch in anderen Ländern, in Österreich zum Beispiel, ging es dann hauptsächlich um Tunnelüberwachung, also Tunnelsicherheit, praktisch nach den verheerenden Unfällen in den Alpentunneln. Also je nachdem, wo man ist und in was für einem Kontext, diskutiert wird, ist die öffentliche Meinung recht unterschiedlich. Dann haben wir halt ein bisschen versucht, uns einen Überblick über die Verbreitung eigentlich zu verschaffen, weil es gibt keine Zahlen darüber, wieviel Kameras gibt es eigentlich in Europa oder in einzelnen Ländern. Also auch wo Registrierungspflichten bestehen, wird keine einzelne Kamera gezählt. Das haben wir versucht, dann haben wir mit Leuten gesprochen, wie sie das empfinden.
Du sagst, ihr habt versucht Kameras zu zählen, ist es euch gelungen?
Naja, also wir hatten, das ist ganz interessant, obwohl Großbritannien sehr stark überwacht ist, hat man einen sehr offenen Umgang damit. Also die britischen Kollegen hatten wesentlich weniger Probleme damit, Informationen zu bekommen, als wir. Wir haben es auf der Friedrichstraße gemacht, sind in den Einzelhandel rein und haben versucht mit den Leuten zu sprechen. Und teilweise waren die nicht mal willens, uns zu sagen, wer eigentlich der Betreiber der Kamera ist. Also ein Drittel der Leute, die wir da, also ein Drittel praktisch der Kameras, die wir entdeckt haben, oder die Systeme, die wir entdeckt haben, da waren die Leute nicht bereit, uns zu sagen, wer die Kameras eigentlich betreibt.
Hätten sie das tun müssen?
Eigentlich hätten sie es tun müssen, ja. Eigentlich hätten sie, das war auch, also man kann, ich glaube, wir hatten 80 Prozent, die praktisch mehr oder weniger illegal betrieben wurden, sind quasi nicht ausgeschildert waren. Also keinen Hinweis darauf gehabt.
Wo muss der Hinweis sein? Direkt, also prominent am Eingang oder?
Ja, deutlich sichtbar soll er sein.
Drei Meter über dem Kopf als zehn Zentimeter kleine Schäden, so wie es die BVG macht oder die S-Bahn. Nee, also es gibt ja schon, entweder müssen die Kameras deutlich sichtbar sein, das ist worauf sich die Bundesbehörden zurückziehen. Das heißt, da sind also keine Schilder, sondern die sagen, die sieht ja klar.
Ja, aber da gab es eine Intervention vom Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten und daraufhin haben sie die Praxis geändert.
Und die haben die Kameras abgebaut oder Schilder angemacht?
Sie haben Schilder angemacht. Man muss noch § 6b Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, müssen private Betreiber und Bundesbehörden, sie müssen darauf hinweisen, da war das Argument der Bundesregierung, man sieht ja die Kameras, aber es muss halt auch der Betreiber sichtlich sein. Nur weil da eine Kamera hängt, weiß ich nicht, wer der Betreiber ist. Also insofern ist, würde ich sagen, schon eine Hinweispflicht gegeben.
Wir haben übrigens als CCC eine Kampagne gemacht, mit anderen Organisationen auch zusammen, nämlich einen Fragebogen entworfen, um genau herauszufinden, wer sitzt eigentlich hinter der Kamera, wer guckt sich das an. Den gibt es bei uns als PDF zum Downloaden. Auf der Seite müsst ihr euch zur Videoüberwachung durchklicken. Das ist sozusagen eine Vorlage, ein Formbrief, den man dann an den Betreiber zum Beispiel ein Geschäft geben kann und sagen, hier wird öffentlicher Raum gefilmt. Und was ist jetzt eigentlich mit den Daten? Werden die gespeichert? Wer guckt sich die an? Und so weiter.
Nutzt das was? Also angenommen, alle würden das machen. Müssen wir den Leuten nur, müssen wir denen, die uns überwachen wollen, nur lang genug auf den Keks gehen, damit sie die Lust dran verlieren?
Na teilweise glaube ich, würden sie schon die Lust verlieren, weil die Praxis sich als illegaler ausstellen würde. Wenn sie es entsprechend zurücknehmen müssten, wie es halt der Dussmann-Fall gezeigt hat. Da hat ein Journalist geklagt, dass man die Überwachung massiv einschränken müsse.
Die wissen das ja teilweise selber nicht, was sie da machen, dass es illegal ist.
Das liegt ja auch daran, dass diese Kameras so billig verkauft werden. Du kannst eine Funkkamera, so ein Ding, für 50-60 Euro irgendwo kaufen mittlerweile. Und jeder Hans Wurst klebt sich halt so eine Kamera ran und möglicherweise mit einem Langzeitvideorekorder und speichert alles nach Herz und Lust. Es ist halt auch gar nicht das... Leute wissen gar nicht, was sie da tun oder denken gar nicht darüber nach, dass sie möglicherweise auch in die Freiheit von anderen Leuten eingreifen.
So, und jetzt haben wir Erik das Wort die ganze Zeit weggenommen. Eigentlich sollte er über seine Forschungsergebnisse berichten. Das machen wir nach den Nachrichten, da haben wir dann ein bisschen mehr Musa als vor den Nachrichten auf die Schnelle.
Dann Fritz in Pankow, dann 100, 2, 6.
Eine voll bei uns.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht erwarten uns mal mehr, mal weniger Wolken, teilweise regnet es. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen 18 und 14 Grad. Am Tage bleibt es dann meistens wolkig und es gibt einzelne Schauer und Gewitter. Nur im Süden Brandenburgs ist es weitgehend heiter. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 30 bis 35 Grad.
In Ostdeutschland drohte in den kommenden 15 Jahren ein massiver Stellenverlust. Laut einer Studie der Bundesagentur für Arbeit könnten bis zu 1 Millionen Jobs verloren gehen. Die Aussichten seien damit noch schlechter als vor Jahren angenommen, heißt es. Im größten Kinderschänderprozess Frankreichs hat ein Gericht die Urtate gesprochen. Die Richter verhängten hohe Haftstrafen. Die über 60 Täter hatten insgesamt 45 Kinder missbraucht. Das jüngste Opfer war sechs Monate alt. Die britischen Sicherheitsbehörden haben am Abend die Festnahme eines der vier verhinderten Selbstmordattentäter vom vergangenen Donnerstag bestätigt. Dabei handelt es sich um einen 24-jährigen Somalier. Nach den anderen drei Tätern wird weiterhin gefahndet. Ein Großbrand hat gestern eine Ölplattform vor der Westküste Indiens zerstört. Nach offiziellen Angammelten kamen drei Arbeiter ums Leben, 45 werden noch vermisst. Die Ölfelder dort liefern mehr als ein Drittel des von Indien geförderten Öls. Zum Fußball Schalke 04 hat durch ein 2 zu 1 über Werder Bremen das Liga-Pokalfinale gegen den VfB Stuttgart erreicht. Der Verkehr Fritz hat keine Meldungen, der Rundfunk mit dem Brandenburg wünscht eine gute Fahrt.
Und dankt Matthias Gerkhoff eine Minute nach halb eins.
Hier spricht die Zeltplatzleitung. Guten Morgen, liebe Camping-Freunde.
Fritz sendet.
Die lange Fritz-Sommernacht des Campings.
Alles um und übers Zelten. Eure Geschichten über durchgeringete Zelte, Rezepte für einflammige Gaskocher, die erfolgsversprechendsten Mücken-Abwehr-Strategien und Tipps für die schönsten Campingplätze in Berlin, Brandenburg, Europa und der Welt.
Mit den Radio-Fritzen Marco Seifert und Nicole Markwald im Studio und Fritz-Reportern unterwegs.
Eine lange Nacht lang.
Die lange Fritz-Sommernacht des Campings.
Morgen Abend ab 22 Uhr, die ganze lange Sommernacht des Morgens um 6.
Mehr Infos fritz.de und im Radio.
M-Sport im Chaosradio 104. Im Wesentlichen geht es um Kameraüberwachung, um Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand. Das Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand, Frank, du musst das nächste Mal dir einen anderen Titel für die Sendung ausdenken. Ich kann mir das nicht merken.
Zwischen London und Bundestagswahl.
Sicherheitswahn auf dem Prüfstand und eure Meinung, eure Haltung unter 0331 70 97 1 1 0. 20 Minuten ungefähr haben wir noch Zeit, haben noch einiges zu erzählen und einiges zu telefonieren. So zum Beispiel mit Marc aus Freiburg, der noch einen Nachtrag hat. Marc Nesium. Ach so, warte mal, Marc jetzt? Wunderbar, jetzt geht's.
Ich musste ein bisschen warten, aber ich hab die Zeit prima genutzt. Ich war in der Zwischenzeit beim Media Markt und hab auch meine Meinung zur Kameraüberwachung natürlich ein bisschen geändert. In der Zwischenzeit hier 30 Kameras installiert, wo ich meinen Nachbarn Tag und Nacht ein bisschen im Blick hab.
Können wir kurz deine Adresse haben?
Ja, ich hab's auch schon ins Internet gestellt. Es richtet sich natürlich auch jetzt an meinen Nachbarn, wenn sie sich selber sehen wollen. Gut, Spaß beiseite. Mich würde, ja fangen wir vielleicht mit einem kleinen Nachbarn, ich muss unbedingt loswerden, vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Satz, obwohl es nichts mit dem Thema zu tun haben noch bezüglich dieser etwas politisch nicht korrekten Aussage vorhin. Von wegen, die nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze weg.
Da kriegen die Arbeit hingeschmissen.
Ja, ich denke einfach, wir haben doch hier in Deutschland ein Demografieproblem. Warum machen wir nicht einfach die Tore auf, lassen die Leute rein? Haben wir wegen wieder genügend Leute, die für uns die Rente einzahlen? Und damit hätten wir gar kein Problem.
Ich gehe gerade mal kurz mit auf den Exkurs und nur ganz kurz. Es gibt nicht genug Arbeit zu einem geringen Entgelt in Deutschland. Und wenn du die Tore aufmachst, ob du die Tore aufmachst oder sie zumachst, ist im Grunde genommen vollkommen egal, solange du so einen hohen Sockel an Arbeitslosen hast. Und dieser hohe Sockel an Arbeitslosen, der kommt zumindest nach meinem Dafürhalten daher, dass zwar Arbeit da ist, diese Arbeit aber nicht zu den üblichen Löhnen gemacht werden kann und die Leute darum zu Hause bleiben und vom Staat alimentiert werden. Also dem Staat versprechen müssen, dass sie nicht arbeiten gehen und dafür dann Geld bekommen. Wenn wir in der Lage wären, arbeiten zu gehen für einen Euro die Stunde, dann hätten wir Vollbeschäftigung. Aber in der Lage sind wir nicht. So, und da kannst du Tore aufmachen oder zumachen, das ist egal. Es ist einfach nicht genügend Arbeit da für einen minimalen Lohn.
Ich meine, diese Leute haben ja auch Bedürfnisse. Die bauen vielleicht ein Häuschen. Na ja, wenn ihr jetzt gerade aus Nordafrika kommt, wird er wahrscheinlich kein Häuschen bauen, aber trotzdem hat er Bedürfnisse und das schafft auch wieder Arbeit.
Ja natürlich, aber nichtsdestotrotz, er kann ja nichts arbeiten. Das Problem ist ja, er würde vielleicht, er würde vielleicht, also es gibt eine große Menge an Arbeit, die ist auf dem Markt, es ist ja ein Markt, da wird Arbeit angeboten. Diese Arbeit ist wert 1 Euro pro Stunde. Du kannst aber in diesem Land nicht für 1 Euro pro Stunde arbeiten gehen. So funktioniert das gesamte System nicht, weil das Problem ist ja, dass selbst wenn du für 1 Euro pro Stunde du arbeiten gingest, würde der Staat sofort von dir verlangen, dass du dich sozialversicherst. Und das wäre von diesem Gehalt überhaupt nicht möglich. Also da ist ein Fehler im System. Also das ist aber auch dumm, das jetzt zu diskutieren, weil das gehört überhaupt nicht in diese Sendung.
Gehen wir über zum eigentlichen Thema. Ich hatte noch die Frage, was mich einfach interessieren würde, von den Zuhörern, die jetzt zu Hause lauschen, wenn ihr denn Gegenvideoüberwachung seid und ihr latscht jetzt über die Straße, so wie in Freiburg. Und da gibt es dann einen Laden, der filmt quer über die Straßenbahnschienen bis auf die andere Seite rüber. Oder das LP ist eine Diskothek, die filmt nachts die halbe Straße. Oder das Exit, was eine Kamera installiert hat, was den Mädels wirklich in den Ausschnitt reingafft, wenn die an der Kasse stehen.
Ist die Kamera online?
Die ist nicht online, nee. Wenn ich sowas wiederfinden sollte, dann melde ich mich. Ist nett, danke. Ja, erstens, was geht euch da durch den Kopf? Entwickelt ihr, also bei mir geht es immer so, dass ich so eine richtige Wut empfinde, weil man auch so ein Stück weit immer, naja, der Dumme ist, der sich dann aufregt, sonst passiert dann doch nichts. Oder wie geht ihr damit um? Schreibt ihr Brief an den Datenschutzbeauftragten? Oder zückt ihr nachts den Fahrtbeutel mit, also es soll jetzt kein Aufruf zur Straftat sein, das ist eine Frage. Mich würde es einfach interessieren, was macht ihr dann?
Also du kannst natürlich schon dein Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung wahrnehmen, solange du keine Sachbeschädigung dabei begehst. Das heißt also die Substanz darf nicht beschädigt werden der Kamera.
Nein, die Frage richtete sich jetzt eher an die Zuhörer.
Also du möchtest ganz gerne, dass wir den Anrufer diese Frage stellen.
Genau.
Das Problem ist, dass die Sendung gleich zu Ende ist und wir noch von uns aus sehr viel zu erzählen haben. Da hättest du früher mitkommen können.
Ärgerlich, ärgerlich.
Wir tun es auf die Liste.
Wir tun es auf die Liste, genau für in drei Jahren. Marc, danke für deinen Anruf. Und das letzte Wort am Telefon hat Thomas Altlandsberg.
Hallo und ich würde sagen, dass ich, also meiner Meinung nach würde ich sagen, dass man das heutzutage wirklich so straight durchziehen muss, dass man überwacht, weil das ist meiner Meinung nach einfach mal wirklich sicherer, ja, würde ich sagen. Sicherer, wenn man das heutzutage, also diese Kleinigkeiten, die gerade der Mike gesagt hat, dass man am Club da in den Ausschnitt von Frauen reinguckt, ich meine, das sind Kleinigkeiten, aber wenn man dann sieht, die Kriminalität ist heutzutage ziemlich hoch und deswegen denke ich, ist es da schon angebracht, dass man da übersacht und ja, denke ich schon.
Vielleicht genau Erics Thema jetzt, oder?
Ja, also zum einen, die Kriminalität ist nicht höher als vor zehn Jahren war, zumindest wenn man den offiziellen Statistiken glaubt, die natürlich auch nicht die wirkliche Kriminalität widerspiegeln, aber es ist immer überraschend, wie da schnell die Keule rausgezogen wird und das mit wachsender Kriminalität begründet wird, weil die Zahlen das eigentlich nicht hergeben. Aber zur Wirksamkeit von Kameras, also es lässt sich letztlich nicht pauschal beurteilen, weil es wirklich stark davon abhängt, wie wird es gemacht und wo wird es gemacht. Und Videoüberwachen kann so unterschiedlich aussehen, es kann halt eben wirklich nur die Kamera sein, die aufzeichnet, es kann eine Kamera sein, wo Leute dahinter sitzen und auch wenn Leute dahinter sitzen, können es gut ausgebildete oder schlecht ausgebildete Leute sein. Es können Leute sein, die praktisch hoch motiviert sind, weil sie irgendwie, dass ihre letzte Chance ist, einen Job zu haben, es können Leute im Studium sein, die das machen, um sich eben ein bisschen Geld nebenbei zu verdienen, die aber wissen, dass ein halbes Jahr später woanders sind und dementsprechend unmotiviert sind. Pauschal-Uteile gibt es nicht. Es hat in Großbritannien eine große Studie gegeben im Auftrag des Innenministeriums, die kam, oder das Homeoffice hat praktisch diese Studiebeauftragte, da haben die irgendwie 18 Evaluationen, eben praktisch wo Sachen schon untersucht wurden, noch mal zusammengefasst und kam zu dem Ergebnis, dass es also einen kriminalpräventiven Effekt von etwa vier Prozent hätte. Also die Kriminalität praktisch ist in der Gesamtschau um vier Prozent zurückgegangen. Was man also bei dem Aufwand und bei den Kosten, die da irgendwie entstanden sind, man wirklich sagen kann, es klingt nach einem unverhältnismäßigen Eingriff.
Tom, wenn du sagst, also dein Sicherheitsempfinden, also deine subjektive Sicherheit ist höher, wenn du weißt, dass alle möglichen Ecken Kamera überwacht sind. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Das, was jetzt gerade gesagt wurde, das sind ja wirklich Fakten, dass die Kriminalität nicht gestiegen ist.
Darum frage ich, also dein subjektives Empfinden ist, du fühlst dich sicherer, wenn Kameras da sind.
Ja, richtig.
Was müsste passieren, damit du sagst, du jetzt reichst? Was müsste dir persönlich wiederfahren, damit du sagst, Moment mal, jetzt ist der Eingriff in meine Privatsphäre ein zu tiefer Eingriff, ein zu weitgehender Eingriff?
Das wär einfach Homebase. Bei einem zu Hause würde ich sagen, das wär einfach mal viel zu weit.
Das heißt, wenn sie eben wissen, wen du wann angerufen hast, welche Internetseite du dir angeguckt hast.
Richtig. Mir geht's jetzt speziell in diesen offiziellen Teil. Wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mich in die Bahn setze oder wenn ich mit dem Bus unterwegs bin, dann mein ich das wär's.
Alles klar. Danke für deinen Anruf, Tom. Und gute Nacht. Das ist eben das Problem. Es ist einfach da. Tom hat ein erhöhtes Sicherheitsempfinden, wenn er an einem kameraüberwachten Ort ist. Und das lässt sich ja nicht wegdiskutieren. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch das Problem. Das ist auf einer tiefen psychologischen Ebene in einem selber statt. Findest du, dass du das gar nicht aus den Leuten rausbekommst?
Auf der Ebene wird ja teilweise auch politisch argumentiert. Manche Sicherheitspolitiker sagen ganz offen, es geht gar nicht darum, dass wir jetzt unbedingt die Kriminalitätsraten senken oder so Selbstmordanschläge verhindern. Das geht gar nicht im Zweifelsfall, wenn die Leute sich geschickt genug anstellen, sondern was wir erreichen wollen, dass die Bevölkerung sich sicherer fühlt.
Das war das nicht Merkel oder Stoiber?
Das hat man von verschiedensten schon gehört.
Vor kurzem hat man gesagt, dass die Deutschen sich viel zu sicher fühlten. Das fand ich ein sehr bemerkenswertes Zitat. Die Zeit Worte der Woche ist da immer so. Da war das vor ein paar Wochen mal drin. Also normalerweise fühlen sich die Deutschen viel zu sicher.
Dass die immer nach so Anschlägen sagen, es muss jetzt was gemacht werden, damit die Leute sich sicherer fühlen. Das ist dann auch eher symbolische Politik. Da frage ich mich schon, was für eine Rolle hat Politik da noch? Wenn man nur sozusagen das Gefühl der Leute verbessert oder wenn man die reale Lage verbessert.
Hatten wir deine Forschungsergebnisse, Entschuldige, Erics Forschungsergebnisse schon irgendwie jetzt zu verfriedigend abgegrast?
Selber in dem Projekt haben wir das nicht untersucht, inwieweit Videoüberwachung effektiv ist. Das, was ich eben gesagt habe, sind letztlich existierende Studien.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz versuchen, den Bogen zu spannen von dieser Kameraüberwachungsdiskussion, Videoüberwachungsdiskussion zu anderen Formen von Überwachung. Bei den Kameras ist ja eigentlich noch vergleichsweise harmlos. Da wird man sozusagen, wenn man im Supermarkt irgendwo rumläuft oder auch auf dem öffentlichen Platz oder in der U-Bahn oder sowas, wird erstmal nur mein Gesicht gefilmt oder was ich da mache. Das wird maximal 24 Stunden aufgehoben, im privaten Bereich teilweise 48 Stunden. Danach werden die Bänder wieder gelöscht. Da weiß aber erstmal noch keiner, wer ist denn dieser Typ, der in der U-Bahn sitzt. Also es ist eigentlich erstmal noch relativ anonym. Es gibt aber ja Anstrengungen in anderen Bereichen, wo das viel viel klarer identifiziert werden kann. Also die Pläne der EU-Innenminister im Moment zur Datenvorratsspeicherung im Internet oder auch von Handydaten, wo wirklich immer ja unmittelbar zurückverfolgt werden kann über den Provider. Wer hat denn da jetzt diese Webseite besucht? Oder wer hat wem welche E-Mails geschickt? Oder welches Handy, das natürlich auch auf einen bestimmten Namen registriert ist normalerweise, war wann, wo, in welcher Funkzelle eingeloggt? Und die Daten sollen zwölf Monate aufbewahrt werden, komplett, für die ganze EU. Das finde ich also eine Sache, die geht wesentlich weiter als diese Kameradiskussion sogar.
Wer bezahlt das? Also wer bezahlt diese Speicherung? Weil irgendwer muss diese Festplatten kaufen, worauf das gespeichert ist, und diese Festplatten irgendwo einbauen.
Ja, da gibt es jetzt eine interessante Allianz von Bürgerrechtsorganisationen und der Privatwirtschaft, weil die ganzen Internetprovider auch Sturm laufen gegen diese EU-Pläne und sagen, das wird alles monströs teuer. Die großen Firmen, AOL und sowas, die könnten sich das eventuell noch leisten. Die müssen einfach riesige Serverfarben aufbauen und terabyteweise Festplatten da irgendwo installieren, das alles speichern. Die Auswertung wird dann eh noch ein technisches Problem hinterher. Aber kleine Provider können sich das zum Teil gar nicht leisten. Die sagen dann, nee, das wird uns zu teuer. Und der Staat hat effektiv nicht das Geld, um den sämtlichen Kosten zu erstatten. Aber mein Punkt ist nur, dass man da viel direkter auch Leute überwachen kann. Wenn jemand sehr viel im Netz ist und da mit Freunden Kontakt hält, einkaufen geht, Zeitung liest oder sowas, da kann man ja wirklich anhand der Log-Dateien, auch wenn man nur die Verkehrsdaten speichert, nicht mal die Inhalte, kann man ja schon sagen, man hat, was weiß ich, zehn Minuten auf der und der Webseite verbracht, bevor man dann zehn Minuten später auf die nächste Webseite geklickt hat. Das heißt, man kann direkt den Leuten individuell zuorten, wer hat wie lange welche Artikel auf irgendeiner Online-Zeitung oder sonst wo gelesen. Und das geht ja wesentlich weiter als...
Und wie hat er sich danach verhalten?
Ja, zum Beispiel. Und das geht ja wesentlich weiter als die Kameraüberwachung, wo man erstmal überhaupt nicht weiß, wer ist diese Person. Und es wird ja auch im Supermarkt nicht von den Kameras genau gespeichert, welches Regal hat sich welcher Mensch wie lange angeguckt oder so.
Obwohl das doch wahrscheinlich ein leichtes wäre, oder?
Ja, die gucken natürlich schon, wo auch... Ich glaube, da werden diese Supermarktkameras auch für genutzt. Wo stehen die Kunden länger rum und gucken sich die Ware an. Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Sozusagen auch zum Marktforschungszwecken. Aber das ist dann eher analogisch.
Das habe ich mal kennengelernt. Und zwar gibt es so eine Firma, die... Ich weiß nicht, die meisten Shopping-Malls in Deutschland irgendwie geplant und gebaut hat. Und die werten tatsächlich aus. Also da habe ich mich mal mit so einem Pressesprecher unterhalten.
Da kann man ja auch irgendwie...
Wir stellen da eine Marmor-Säule hin, damit die Leute da langlaufen und sich diese Show-Finster auch noch angucken.
Aber dann sind die Leute, die da langlaufen, erstmal anonym. Da kannst du auch Strichlisten machen und jemanden hinsetzen, das mitzählt. Aber wenn ich das im Internet mache, kann man ja unmittelbar den Personen zuordnen. Was haben sie? Wie lange da gemacht? Welche Waren oder was weiß ich, haben sie sich wie lange angeguckt? Da ist die Gefahr für die Privatsphäre viel größer. Und da gibt es auch einen ziemlich großen Graubereich zwischen was ist noch meine Privatsphäre, my home oder sowas, und was ist öffentlicher Raum, wo ich auch beobachtet werden darf. Und das wollte ich noch einmal gegen Ende der Sendung darauf hinweisen. Gegen diese Pläne der EU- Innenminister zur Datenvorratsspeicherung, also verpflichtende 12 Monate lange Datenspeicherung, Weichung sämtlicher Internetverbindungsdaten, also sozusagen den ganzen Clickstream, wie man es immer so nennt, gibt es A, Widerstand aus dem Europäischen Parlament schon seit einer Weile, die da echt Rückendeckung brauchen, und es gibt seit, naja, jetzt haben wir Donnerstag schon, also seit heute eine internationale Kampagne dazu von diversen europäischen Organisationen, gestartet von ein paar holländischen Internetprovidern zusammen mit dem Dachverband der europäischen Bürgerrechtsorganisation im Internet, der nennt sich European Digital Rights, ist unter www.edri.org zu finden. Da gibt es eine Kampagne gegen diese Datenvorratspeicherung der EU, da kann man auch die Petition unterzeichnen, und da wird sich in nächster Zeit noch einiges tun.
Wie groß ist der Widerstand aus dem Europäischen Parlament?
Der ist zumindest mehrheitlich. Also es gab vor ein paar Monaten...
Und wer ist der Widerstand des Widerstands? Also wer hätte gerne diese Datenspeicherung? Lässt sich das in irgendwelchen Lagern festmachen, oder geht das quer durch alle Parteien?
Das geht zum Teil quer durch die Parteien. Das ist eher sozusagen, wer aus der Sicherheitspolitik kommt, innenpolitik oder sowas als Hintergrund hat. Das kann dann auch ein Sozialdemokrat sein, oder ein Konservativer oder so, das ist relativ wurscht. Der ist eher für Überwachung. Die Leute, die Wirtschaftspolitik machen, die Internetpolitik machen und sowas, sind tendenziell dagegen. Und im Europäischen Parlament gibt es seit Jahr und Tag eine relativ deutliche Mehrheit gegen diese Pläne. Also so ähnlich wie das bei Softwarepatenten auch gelaufen ist vor einer Weile. EU Kommission und RAT will irgendwas, was wir nicht so toll finden als User. Und das Parlament ist eher auf unserer Seite. Und das sollte man da sozusagen auch unterstützen.
Gibt es, Erik, gibt es von dir noch irgendwelche interessanten Links, wo die Leute vielleicht noch mal was nachlesen können? Statistiken oder sowas zur Kamerabewachung? Hast du etwas parat?
Also zum einen natürlich die Projektwebseite, die wir haben, wobei da leider alles auf Englisch ist. Das ist www.urbanet.net. Und dann ist es so, dass ich auch in einem Arbeitskreis Videoüberwachung und Bürgerrechte mitarbeite, dessen Website lange Zeit ziemlich tot war. Das sieht wohl aber so aus, als ob die jetzt demnächst wiederbelebt wird.
Mit so Fotos.
Und das ist dann aufzurufen, da sind die Informationen dann auf Deutsch und das soll auch relativ interaktiv dann werden, wenn es soweit ist, das wird dann unter akvue.de laufen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir dann Mitte August mit im Start sind.
Was ich noch empfehlen kann zum Thema generell Bürgerrechte im Internet, ist das wunderbare Blog von unserem Freund Markus Becke Dahl unter netzpolitik.org. Da gibt es auch mal ganz viel zu aktuellen Entwicklungen im Bereich Datenschutz, Internetüberwachung.
Der macht auch, Markus macht auch den ganzen Tag nichts anderes.
Super.
Hut ab.
Ach so, die Kampagne von Edri und den anderen, die hat auch eine eigene Website, die ist leider ein bisschen lang, aber wenn man Englisch kann, recht einfach zu merken. www.dataretentionisnosolution.com glaube ich sogar komischerweise.
Ja, edri.org ist vielleicht das einfachste, ansonsten ctc.de. Da wird es sicherlich dann auch zu dieser Sendung den ein oder anderen Begleittext geben, mit dem ein oder anderen Begleitlink.
Nicht wahr? Und bei chaosradio.de werden auch die Links dann nochmal drauf stehen, oder?
Können wir den machen, also müssen wir ihn dazu schicken und so, das kriegen wir ja schön, da packen wir das drauf. Wer noch ganz spontan, schnell und entschlossen nach Holland fahren will, so what the heck, da findet ja gerade ein Camp statt.
Auf dem Camp haben sie gerade diese Kampagne auch gestartet. Da sitzt jetzt zum Beispiel der besagte Markus und übersetzt es schnell auf Deutsch, die Petition.
Fahren wir schnell hin, ich hab gerade ein Diesel vollgetan.
Das Wetter ist glaube ich leider gerade nicht so prall.
Aber es soll morgen 35 Grad, in Berlin ja. Bleiben wir lieber hier.
Nee, wird schon, wir drücken euch die Daumen auf jeden Fall in Holland und habt schönes Wetter, habt Spaß am Wochenende. Ich selbst bin leider auch nicht da. Aber ja, wird bestimmt lustig. Also wer da noch spontan hin will, www.whattheheck.org glaube ich.
Ansonsten Edri Org. Vielen Dank Frank.
Vielen Dank Erik.
Voll bei seinen Namensgedächtnissen.
Nein, ich wollte vor allen Dingen Bendrad. Deinen Nachnamen hatte ich gerade im Kopf und der Vorname war weg. Das war super, ich hätte jetzt Herr B gesagt.
Bendrad ist eh besser, findet man unter Google leichter.
Ralf, nicht so.
Ralf gibt es zu viele.
Gut, danke, dass ihr hier wart. Das war Chaosradio 104, war das, was ihr gehört habt. Chaosradio gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, so also auch dann am, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, 30.08. Ja, am letzten Mittwoch, genau, am letzten Mittwoch im August gibt es das nächste Chaosradio hier auf Fritz. Dann auch wieder um 22 Uhr. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Es geht weiter mit dem Night Flight. 31.08. 31.08.? Juli und August haben beide 31 Tage. Ich bin wirklich ein Maße begeistert. So, nochmal ab 1 Uhr Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Ich bin Holger Klein.